[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre grande
mission parlementaire du mercredi nous
sommes ensemble jusqu'à 17 heures trois
heures d'émission et un point d'orgue
dans une heure les questions d'actualité
au gouvernement
l'occasion pour les sénateurs d'
interpeller l'exécutif sur sa gestion de
l'affairé rivaux et le départ précipité
d'agnès busin du gouvernement pour la
campagne parisienne mais aussi bien
d'autres sujets dont on va parler avec
alice bardot dans l'hémicycle et
alexandre poussard salle des conférences
pour toutes les réactions lutter contre
le séparatisme sans stigmatiser les
musulmans
c'est l'objectif dévoilé hier par
emmanuel macron le président de la
république veut notamment lutter contre
les influences extérieures et cesser
d'accueillir les imams détachées c'est
notre débat à 14 heures enfin la
fermeture de fessenheim aura bien lieu
plusieurs fois annoncée plusieurs fois
repoussé voilà que la promesse est tenue
par l'exécutif
le réacteur numéro 1 s'arrêtera samedi
mais le démantèlement va se dérouler sur
au moins 20 ans on y revient à 14h30
n'hésitez pas à réagir a commenté cette
émission avec le hashtag qu âgées
[Musique]
et on va tout de suite rejoindre alice
bardot dans l'hémicycle du sénat s'est
pour l'instant très calme derrière vous
mais dans une heure vont commencer les
questions d'actualité alors comment ça
va se passer
eh bien sans surprise tam cet après midi
les sénateurs vont interpeller le
gouvernement sur les mesures annoncées
hier par emmanuel macron pour lutter
contre le séparatisme islamistes il y
aura donc deux questions à ce sujet et
ce dès l'ouverture de la séance une
séance de questions d'actualité qui sera
également marquée en fin ou du moins qui
aura l'alluré d'un baptême du feu pour
olivier ferrand le remplaçant d'agnès
busan à la santé l'ancien député lrm
arrive en pleine épidémie deux grenades
et de corona virus et au début de
l'examen de la réforme des retraites
autant de sujets sur lesquels il va être
interpellé
tout à l'heure notamment par la gauche
de l'hémicycle
voilà pour un aperçu du programme de ces
questions au gouvernement on se retrouve
tout à l'heure juste avant l'ouverture
de la séance
effectivement aller si on vous retrouve
vers 15h vous en avez parlé le
séparatisme islamistes c'est l'un des
sujets abordés dans une heure lors des
questions d'actu et c'est tout de suite
l'objet dans notre premier débat après
la visite de terrain est fière des
manuels macron dans l'un des quartiers
sensibles de mulhouse
l'occasion pour lui de présenter son
plan de lutte contre le séparatisme
islamistes alors que penser des annonces
du président de la république
répond-t-elle aux besoins ou sont-elles
insuffisante et quelles sont les
intentions derrière ce plan on en débat
dans un instant mais d'abord on fait le
point sur les annonces de l'exécutif
avec pierre henry holder boom attendu
depuis plusieurs mois par la droite
le président de la république s'est
rendu hier à mulhouse pour dévoiler son
projet sur le communautarisme qu'il
préfère appeler séparatisme dans la
république on ne peut pas accepter qu'on
refuse de serrer la main à une femme
parce qu'elle est femme dans la
république on ne peut pas accepter
d'être que quelqu'un refuse d'être
soignés ou éduquer par quelqu'un parce
que c'est une femme dans la république
on ne peut pas accepter la
déscolarisation pour des raisons
religieuse ou de croyance dans la
république on ne peut pas exiger des
certificats de virginité pour se marier
dans la république
on ne doit jamais accepté que les lois
de la religion puisse être supérieure
aux lois de la république c'est aussi
simple que ça pour emmanuel macron il y
a quatre points à régler lutter contre
la fluence étrangères mieux organiser le
culte musulman ainsi que lutter contre
les manifestations séparatistes et
surtout réaffirmer la présence de la
république dans certains quartiers pour
le patron des sénateurs socialistes
patrick kanner le diagnostic du
président de la république est juste
mais les mesures déçoivent le mot de
séparatisme est un mot intelligent parce
que d'abord le communautarisme voire
même la radicalisation ce n'est pas un
délit dans notre pays la question qui
est posée c'est ce qu'ils veulent
utiliser la religion comme un moyen de
supplanter les lois de la république et
chargé tout à fait condamnable donc le
président pose diagnostic pour ce qui
concerne les solutions elles sont encore
permettez moi l'expression assez light
pour le député yannick jadot la mesure
du président sur l'ingérence étrangère
est ambiguë à la fois il dit faut
contrôler l'argent de l'étranger faut
contrôler les imams ou les enseignants
en leur venant de l'étranger
mais en même temps il donne cette
responsabilité-là au cfcm qui est depuis
son origine malheureusement davantage
une représentation des pays d'origine ou
que d'une représentation des français
musulmans
un dossier sensible à quelques semaines
des municipales le président de la
république s'exprimera à nouveau sur ces
sujets dans les semaines à venir et on
va revenir sur toutes ces annonces inde
emmanuel macron sur ce plateau avec
gilbert roger bonjour vous êtes sénateur
socialiste de la seine saint denis
ancien maire de bondy également sur ce
plateau philippe dallier sénateur l ère
de la seine saint denis vice président
du sénat et vous vous aviez temer des
pavillons-sous-bois également sur ce
plateau samuel gibbons ce qui est
bienvenu vous êtes fondateur de
l'association coexister c'est un
mouvement d'éducation populaire très
présent dans les quartiers populaires et
qui promeut le vivre ensemble
enfin sur ce plateau claude posternak
merci d'être sûr que ce plateau
fondateur du site l'important point fr
et membre du bureau exécutif de la
république en marche merci messieurs de
participer à ce débat d'abord un mot sur
le fait que macron haye sur ce terrain
là tout simplement
est-ce que c'est nécessaire philippe
dallier quelles sont les intentions pour
vous à de l'exécutif mais c'est super ça
faisait un moment qu'on attendait le
discours le fameux discours du président
de la république sur la laïcité bon là
on n'est pas sûr c'était celui-là
d'ailleurs oui voilà c'est toute la
question enfin que le président de la
république finissent par s'exprimer sur
ce sujet là j'ai envie de dire tant
mieux parce que le moins qu'ils
pouvaient faire s'est effectivement de
nous dire quelle était sa conception des
choses
et puis surtout quelle mesure il entend
prendre bon sur les mesures ça avait
plutôt été l'égérie hier effectivement
des choses à venir donc là mais il était
temps j'ai envie de dire parce qu'il y
ait un problème qui se pose oui il était
temps j'ai dérogé vous êtes d'accord et
que pensez-vous de la teneur de ces
mesures
oui il était temps parce que
on le voit bien comme élus locaux il ya
une dégradation qui est même une
accélération en fait de la décomposition
sociale et moi j'attendais un peu je
n'ai pas entendu un peu plus de retour
de l'état en particulier sur ce que
j'appelle le contrôle de légalité c'est
à dire sur le contrôle que l'état
devrait faire pour vérifier que les
décisions prises par les conseils
municipaux soit dans la république alors
ailleurs on va rester encore un petit
peu sur le constat saml jboss ski c'est
un frein réel qui est pointé du doigt
pour vous un problème d'ailleurs dont la
responsabilité est partagée par tous
simples puisque c'est le résultat aussi
de la gestion de la droite comme de la
gauche
so lu ment c'est un vrai problème et
c'était difficile de le pointer de
manière subtile dont je trouve que le
président la république a réussi à
trouver une cible juste et il fallait
absolument si vous voulez juste parce
que les dommages collatéraux peuvent
être très nombreux d'abord évidemment
que nos concitoyens musulmans qui
peuvent être ciblés injustement dans
cette cible de recherche du séparatisme
islamistes et aussi parce que nadine
s'agit pas de stigmatiser quelque
religion il a pris des précautions et
82e dommage collatéral qui est possible
donc aux citoyens c'est la société tout
entière puisqu'on sait que le terreau de
la violence a toujours été lezak les
attitudes la culture anti musulmanes ou
islamophobes qui favorise la frustration
est donc derrière la violence donc il
fallait cibler juste en revanche je
trouve que si le discours était très
équilibré qui a été ni simpliste ni
naïfs etc
je trouve que sur le quatrième volet qui
est celui de l'inclusion j'aurais
préféré qu'il soit en premier c'est à
dire que pour moi le séparatisme qui
peut être repris par des idéologues
d'arrière qui vont conceptualiser une
société dans la république est d'abord
l'effet d'une exclusion et là c'est le
séparatisme il est d'abord pour moi
d'une société majoritaire qui exclut une
société minoritaire dans laquelle se
construisent ensuite des contres société
et ça il faut le rappeler parce que les
politiques d'inclusion le contrôle
d'égalité pour moi c'est le premier
devoir de la république d'aller lutter
contre ces 20% de chômage qui ont été
nommés mais de dire comment on va faire
et notamment une question que je pose
c'est pourquoi depuis 2010 est le
ministère de la jeunesse et de la vie
associative sont fusionnés avec
l'éducation et ont aussi perdu par la
même occasion des moyens donc
globalement un discours très équilibré
avec pour moi une très grosse
vigilance sur cette inclusion avec la
politique de la ville pardon vous
trouvez que septième quand c'était avec
la politique de la ville aujourd'hui
juste statistiquement canton rennes le
budget de l'état qui a été votée en
décembre le budget pour les associations
et la vie associative a baissé en france
et donc quand on dit on va augmenter les
partenariats avec la société civile
jeudi c'est bien comme intentions mais
comment est ce qu'on va faire comment
est ce qu'on va faire
claude posternak je m'arrête un instant
sur un mois vous avez employé et qu'un
employé hier emmanuel macron bien sûr ce
mot c'est le mot de séparatisme c'est le
mot qu'il a utilisées n'ont pas
communautarisme cela désigne peut-être
plus clairement un groupe qui veut
s'extraire des lois de la république
c'était à un glissement sémantique qui
permet de clarifier les choses à quoi ça
sert pour vous oui je pense que ça
permet de clarifier mais c'est un mot
qui pas un mot nouveau
il a déjà été employé plusieurs fois
dans un contexte religieux dans un
contexte politique la dernière fois en
france était le général de gaulle qui
parlait de séparatisme en parlant du
parti communiste au moment de la guerre
froide
au niveau politique qui correspond à un
autre sujet c'est un mot qui avait
d'abord été employé par le courant de
chevènement quand il y avait encore un
courant chevènement qui parlait des
sauvageons c'est le premier qui a
employé ce terme cat et repris après par
examen de banat terre dont
l'introduction d'un lit vékat et repris
après par kouchner dans une tribune au
figaro on pourra dire que ces
personnalités viennent tout d'un courant
classique classique et qu' il ya à
priori une orientation un peu un
recentrage du président de la république
sur ces sujets là donc c'est un
terminologie wiki forte le prise en
mains publiques employaient 1 mots
extrêmement forts alors d'autre part sur
ses interventions il ya beaucoup
d'éléments et par nature la
communication et univoque alors l'aiment
bien retenir une chose et c'est très
difficile de retenir une chose sur des
sujets aussi complexes je pense que la
première partie du président lorsqu'il
dit ce qui a été fait depuis deux ans
n'est pas suffisamment repris
l'identification de cars de quartiers
prioritaires 1,47 quartier mais quartier
de reconquête république de reconquête
les 47 plus y en a 15 qui ont été isolés
parmi les 47 parce qu'on s'est rendu
compte qu'il y avait des quartiers où il
y avait des phénomènes de deuil et
djihadisme
coup de jeune et est partie au jihad en
syrie en irak donc on a voulu mettre un
focus dessus donc le président de la
république a été dans un quartier à
mulhouse qui justement dans les 47
aidants et dans les dents les hackers
exactement et on peut dire quand même
que depuis deux ans et un redéploiement
déjà de la force publique puisqu'il ya
1600 gendarmes et policiers
en plus il y a eu d'effet de contrôle
d'école qui ont été fermés de débits de
boissons qui ont été fermés c'est à dire
qu'il ya une action mais où je vous
rejoins c'est que ça suffit pas donné d
acte où il faut sanctionner lorsqu'on
est hors de la république il faut
répondre aussi par par des réponses qui
sont des réponses sociales philippe
dallier justement pour revenir sur ces
quartiers de reconquête républicaine et
y en a quelques-uns en seine saint denis
vous vous constatez une utilité avec ce
classement de quartier de reconquête
républicaine avec plus de forces de
l'ordre normalement dit à ce qu'il y ait
un changement avec vous écoutez moi je
pense que ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui est
bien mais ça n'est pas à la mesure en la
vie du problème qui nous est posée
effectivement il ya un les quartiers les
plus problématiques qui aujourd'hui font
l'objet d'un certain nombre de mesures
mais si on parle d'un département comme
la seine saint denis je pense qu'il faut
s'y intéresser dans son ensemble il
c'est un département qui doit faire à
peu près deux millions d'habitants
donc je pense qu'il faut changer
d'échelle dans la réponse
et ça j'attends de le voir venir sa
demande des moyens c'est compliqué je ne
dirait pas le contraire mais je pense
qu'il fallait que vous le demande 5 mx
gilbert roger ou mois ou tous les
parlementaires de seine-saint-denis on
pose la question de la présence de
l'état et de la manière dont l'état
effectivement contrôler un certain
nombre de choses donc il faut changer
d'échelle absolument
gilbert roger vous êtes d'accord avec ça
oui oui bien faire parce que
on l'a vu récemment avec le rapport qui
a été fait parlementaires de nos
collègues députés
il ya besoin du retour de l'état mais
bien évidemment dans un certain nombre
de quartiers
il faut y mettre des moyens un peu
supplémentaires et j'aurais presque dire
d'onde de choc pour changer l'état
d'esprit sinon ça va être une vraie
catastrophe où on va confondre les gens
et moi c'est pour ça que j'appréciais le
qualificatif de séparatisme
parce que dans la dans l'imaginaire des
uns et des autres ça permettra de ne pas
confondre avec la pratique religieuse
qui peut être offerte à chacun des
citoyens et librement
il est président de la république a
d'ailleurs mis l'accent là dessus lors
de son discours hier emmanuel macron a
aussi parlé des ingérences extérieures
dans l'islam
parmi ces nano et annonce la fin de
l'accueil des imams des tâches et on
écoute ce qu'est la dépouille on en
parle juste après
donc nous allons ainsi progressivement
mettre fin au système des imams
détachées et là aussi de manière
progressive
opsahl mots durs qui sont accueillis
spécifiquement chaque année à l'aube du
ramadan il y en a environ 300
cette sortie de ce qu'on appelle l'islam
consulaire est elle aussi extrêmement
importante pour pouvoir réduire ses
influences étrangères
et là aussi permettre de s'assurer que
chacune et chacun respecte pleinement
les lois de la république dans un cadre
qui connu de tous rappelons un conte
compte aujourd'hui en france 300 imams
détachées permanents dont 150
proviennent de la turquie 120 de
l'algérie est une trentaine du maroc
donc la france passée y est c'est
d'accueillir des imams détachées en
provenance d'autres pays
est-ce que c'était important sa magie
bof ce qui est ce que c'est un problème
important pour vous aujourd'hui dans les
quartiers où est tout à fait alors ce
qui est très frustrant c'est que il ya
eu une potentialité de nouvelles lois ou
réforme sur 1905 sur la laïcité en
passant par des lois périphériques et
qu'en fait ces rumeurs qui sont sortis
dans l'opinion aux moineaux
en octobre je crois ou non c'était l'an
passé pas d'inciter le au printemps
dernier n'ont pas été reprises donc à ce
que là on serait sur la suite de ce qui
avait été annoncé
je pense que ça c'est une des mesures
très positives pour empêcher tout
simplement les fantasmes et d'avoir des
personnes qui soient formés en france
en revanche là où je pense qu'à ça et je
pas si on parle de fantasmes il ya une
égalité mais qui s'assoient sur le
financement des lieux de culte
associations cultuelles ou culturelles
écouter on sait très bien comment ça se
passe sur le terrain
que ça soit effectivement sur ces imams
qui viennent d'ailleurs et qui viennent
prêcher une parole qui n'est pas tout à
fait celle de la république au delà du
discours religieux classique
tout ça ça existe donc ça bouge pas dans
les fantasmes je parle de contrôle serre
que le jour où on aura des îles alors ne
parlez pas du fantasme c'est pas la même
chose alors en fait ces raisons il ya
une réalité qui est fantasmé parce
qu'elle est extrapolé et donc pour que
cette réalité suscite de notre part
notre défi lancé à notre implication
faut qu'on puisse la connaître est ce
qu'à fait notamment l'institut montaigne
depuis plusieurs années de mesurer des
problèmes quand il y en a c'est
fondamental mais au moins de les
connaître quand les imams sont étrangers
ces sont des circuits des rouages des
recrutements qu'on ne connaît pas un mur
ou d'accords langil des langues qui ne
sont pas les l'autre sur le fait que
plus on se rapproche actes et du contact
exactement en revanche là où moi je me
pose une question c'est que en amont de
ce discours beaucoup d'associations ont
quand même été consulté la société
civile je veux le souligner ça a été
positif
en revanche la majorité des gens qui ont
été entendus pour préparer cette
intervention je trouve sont une majorité
de non musulmans et même pour parler
franchement de blanc et donc je crois
qu'aujourd'hui sur ce travail-là jeu
blanc ce bien sûr ce travail-là de moins
50 ans qu'on a affaire n'a pas profité
voilà l'erreur alors jusqu'à présent
c'est pas suffisant gsm ce matin sur
plusieurs télés le le dire qu'il faut
aller plus loin si on a des mesures qui
concernent le lien entre la religion et
l'état qui sont des liens possibles bien
que séparés il faut que ce ce travail-là
se fasse en impliquant les premiers
concernés je pense que ça c'est quelque
chose qui manque aujourd'hui que le
poster un avis vous voulez intervenir
oui bien sûr qu'il faut rencontrer un
maximum de personnes mais sur d'abord
les fêtes vous avez raison de rappeler
qu'il y avait 300 imams qui les de
l'étranger et pour la plupart qui ne
parle pas français
sur les 300
en difficulté à contrôler les avait
appelés qui en a 150 qui viennent de
turquie donc s'était dit là c'est un
poids démesuré par rapport au poids de
la communauté turque en france et qu'on
sait on connaît les liens entre la
turquie et les frères musulmans
cette année un impact qui n'est pas un
impact neutre
en plus de ces 300 qui viennent ya 300
autres imams qui viennent au moment du
ramadan pour au moment où il ya un
besoin qui se fait ressentir
simplement il faut aussi ramener les
chiffes ces chiffres sont importants
mais ils sont riches ils sont faibles
par rapport en pourcentage par rapport à
l'ensemble des imams en france
donc faut dire les choses telles
qu'elles sont il faut éviter le fantasme
je te fais d'accord mais il faut dire
les choses telles qu'elles sont les
basques pour vous les prêches
extrémistes ont essentiellement le fait
de ces imams autoproclamés eu de ces
imams venant de l'étranger ou bien aussi
et bien épais avoir d'autres problèmes
avec la table je n'ai pas la réponse à
cette question je pense qu'il faut pour
se poser la question où service de gomis
qui sont chargés effectivement de
surveiller tout cela maintenant je pense
qu'il serait assez naïve de croire que
ça ne peut être que le fait d' imam qui
viennent de l'étranger
mais cette pratique là on doit
effectivement y mettre un terme et
heureusement que enfin le sujet revient
sur la table et que des décisions vont
être prises
la question c'est pourquoi est-ce qu'on
a attendu aussi longtemps tout comme
effectivement trop pourquoi écouter vous
savez j'en reviens choisit pas le
président de la république de
séparatistes tant mieux finalement
mais qui effectivement faisait
l'amalgamé entre les musulmans
pratiquants qui pratiquent leur foi sans
aucun problème et les autres uniquement
ceux qui dans la fachosphère d'un côté
et les autres qui de l'autre côté c'est
effectivement veulent que cet amalgame
soit dans la tête de certains il n'ya
pas pourquoi la région
exactement il n'y a pas de confusion
dans la tête de l'immense majorité des
français encore moins des politiques
quand on veut lutter contre l'islam
politique on sait exactement de quoi on
parle
donc il faut effectivement que l'état le
gouvernement sorte de cette espèce
d'incapacité a agi
parce qu'on aurait peur d'être accusé de
stigmatiser les musulmans
ça c'est quelque chose qui nous a fait
un mal considérable
il faut en sortir personne ici ne
stigmatise les musulmans pratiquement et
non d'ailleurs
il faut agir macheda roger week
obligatoire sujet tabou non
d'optimalisation absolument pas et est
d'autant plus mais on a été plusieurs
maires à le dire ça va être repris dans
le discours d'hier
il ya aussi tout ce qui est
l'accompagnement scolaire qui a été fait
notamment alors on le dit par des turcs
qui viennent souvent dans les écoles
dites de la république prendre des
salles de classe et par des accords
internationaux faire de l'enseignement
sur des livres religieux bien sûr et
tout à fait et est en plus
pas avec l'idée que la république
française pour être un modèle
donc c'est une vraie catastrophe dont on
récupère ses enfants ensuite dans la vie
du quotidien de nos de nos communes
je vous interromps car on va tout de
suite se rendre salle des conférences on
va rejoindre alexandre poussard vous
êtes avec nathalie delattre sénatrice
rds seul président est bien une
commission d' enquête sur la
radicalisation islamiste qui a débuté
ses travaux et ses nike qui va prendre
en compte d'ailleurs
eh bien les propos est fière des manuels
macrophytes avoue alexandre et oui
nathalie delattre dans votre commission
d' enquête sur la radicalisation comment
vous allez prendre en compte ces mesures
annoncées par le président de la
république mais écoutez d'abord
normalement on nous annonce que ce n'est
pas la preuve c'est la première vague
par seconde annonce donc on va attendre
les épisodes suivants
nous allons bien sûr mettre en place un
suivi de ces annonces mais nous
attendons pardon des des mesures plus
concrètes là on est plutôt sur des
objectifs des cadres très très généraux
ou par parfois il a pu effectivement
rentrer dans le détail on l'a vu sur la
formation des imams donc nous allons
suivre c'est ces annonces
et puis continuer de façon très
indépendante notre travail nous avons
mené beaucoup d'auditions et nous allons
aller maintenant sur le terrain nous
déplacer pour constater certaines
problématiques rencontrées les élus
locaux parce qu'on sait que là aussi il
y a un problème dans le système avec des
élus locaux qui doivent faire face à des
difficultés du quotidien et qui ne sont
pas toujours équipés pour faire face
alors dans vos auditions de la
commission enquête sur la radicalisation
est ce que ce problème de l'influencé
étrangère sur l'islam en france est
ressorti alors nous ne faisons pas ce
que d'autres sénateurs ont pu étudier et
ça a été l'objet du rapport de nathalie
goulet notamment sur les financements
qatar mais on sent bien qu en filigramme
ce cette problématique du financement
est très prégnante
on a pu constater que le halal était une
source de financement pour des gens qui
souhaitent
déstabilisé notre modèle républicain
donc l'influencent étrangères est là et
l'on voit maintenant que cette influence
elle est plutôt local c'est à dire que
ce sont les financements internes qui
peuvent être amenés à financer des
actions de déstabilisation c'est à dire
que ce sont des musulmans français qui
se sentent contraints par le regard que
les autres ont sur eux d'acheter du
halal donc quelque part il n'y a plus
besoin forcément d'avoir des
financements étrangers
alors pour les mosquées pour des gros
financement de ce type là bien sûr mais
pour le quotidien le financement du
pèlerinage
le halal ou d'autres actions de la vie
courante sont qu'un financement interne
trouvé par ces islamistes ce que vous
observez c'est que finalement
l'influencé elle vient et bien de
l'intérieur de ces quartiers pour
évoluer vers un séparatisme
il sait que ses trois et c'est elle
annonce aussi des manuels macron qui m'a
peut-être un peu rassuré ce côté là
c'est que nous ne sommes plus dans le
déni
c'est à dire que ce n'est plus l'objet
d'attaqués extérieures mais on a bien
une problématique à l'intérieur avec des
personnalités qui cherchent à
déstabiliser notre modèle du vivre
ensemble laïc
très bien merci beaucoup nathalie
delattre d'avoir répondu à mes questions
merci beaucoup alexandre pour cette
intervention alors philippe dallier le
sénat énormément à travailler sur les
sujets qui touchent au communautarisme
et à la radicalisation il ya sept
actuellement cette commission d' enquête
mais il ya aussi eu des missions
d'information sur l'islam des travaux
sur la déradicalisation et j'en passe
philippe dallier cela montre à la fois
que la situation allait repérée depuis
longtemps mais qu'aussi bien on a été
largement impuissant à résoudre le
problème malgré tous ces travaux on aura
au moins démontré une chose c'est que le
parlement joue son rôle
effectivement toutes ces commissions
travaillent depuis longtemps rendent des
rapports donc nous jouons notre rôle
et des rapports de qualité gilbert roger
mais encore faut-il ensuite que le
gouvernement quel qu'il soit se saisisse
de ces travaux et c'est vrai que
peut-être allons-nous sortir d'une
espèce de période qui a duré et qui a
trop duré pendant laquelle on n'a pas
osé effectivement nommer les choses et
puis prendre des décisions qui
effectivement peuvent susciter la
critique mais en tous les cas il était
temps que le gouvernement agisse et
agissent fort parce que je le redis ce
problème il vient de loin il ne concerne
pas que des gens qui viennent de
l'étranger il ya aussi des gens qui ont
la nationalité française et qui ne
veulent pas que les lois de la
république soit considéré comme étant
supérieur à certaines lois religieuses
donc il ya tout cela à combattre il faut
le faire fermement en ayant le courage
de dire les choses
alors si on peut sortir de cette
situation qui a trop duré et bien tant
mieux
claude posternak là et donc à la prise
de décision oui nous dit-on alors les
annonces yard emmanuel macron
manifestement elles sont été
insuffisante pour un certain nombre de
lieux
on a parlé d identification de quartier
des forces de police côté une mise en
oeuvre d d d d d d des lieux de culte
qui ont été fermées des débits de
boissons qui ont été fermés on parlait
là ddd zelko je vous rappelle quand même
il ya 80 mille élèves qui fréquentaient
les bâtiments d'éducation nationale avec
à l'intérieur des gens qui n'étaient pas
de l'éducation nationale qui venaient de
différents pays alors ça pouvait aussi
bien la turquie que le portugal s'était
pas simplement en langue en langue arabe
simplement le président décidé d'y
mettre fin c'est une aja de lalo
belkacem a bien dit que ça avait
commencé avant 2016 c'est tout à fait
vraiment tous les cas ces mises en
oeuvre après juste jour et faire une
remarque gramsci disait que les
victoires céder d'abord des victoires
culturel le président de république
lorsqu'il parle de séparatisme y met au
coeur de la république l'article cet
article qui dit que nous sommes dans une
république laïque indivisible
démocratique et sociale bon ça veut dire
quoi indivisible ça veut dire quoi
laïque ça veut dire que il dit qui a
priorité de la république par rapport à
la croyance religieuse pour ça il ya des
mots je crois qu'il faut arrêter de
parler de musulmans de france musulmans
de france ça veut dire qu'on donne la
priorité à la religion par rapport au
pis s'il faut parler d'un français
musulman français musulmans c'est des
termes extrêmement simple qui rappelle
qu'on dit en premier ce qui nous unit et
puis en deux qui fait son altérité
mais c'est des choses qu'on doit
pratiquer nous au quotidien pour changer
la donne pour montrer véritablement que
nous remettons cet article un haut sens
de toute la démarche politique qui la
nôtre effectivement moi je trouve que la
sémantique a énormément de sang sont dit
on part on parle de mots parlent de mots
c'est pas vrai les mots c'est
fondamental ça recouvre des choses il y
avait plein de débat d'ailleurs qui sont
des débats derrière qui regroupe des
vraies réalités là sur la question de ce
qu'est la confusion je pense que la
confusion se lève
en revanche il ya encore une
concentration on a parlé de comment est
ce que la loi 1905 aujourd'hui prévoient
déjà une police des cultes qui est peu
connu c'est un des articles de la fin de
la loi entre 40 et 45 je sais plus qui
prévoit cette police à la fois pour
empêcher que les lieux de culte soient
des lieux de réunions syndicales ou
politiques mais aussi pour empêcher que
les croyants soient dérangés dans leur
exercice du culte qui est une liberté
fondamentale aujourd'hui protégées
notamment par l'article 18 des droits
humains et l'article 10 de 1789
en revanche dans cette concentration
aujourd'hui ce qui m'inquiète c'est
qu'on ne parle que de phénomènes
musulmans alors c'est vrai que vis-à-vis
de l'islam le séparatisme islamiste est
plus visible et plus palpable vous le
voyez notamment l'anglo témoignages 193
mais si on parle par exemple des prêches
avec mon expérience je fais 90 de culte
par an je peux vous dire que des prêches
qui invite à désobéir aux lois de la
république ou à faire scission ne sont
pas que le fait de musulmans des prêches
qu'il ya invite à empêcher l'accès à
l'avortement
l'accès au droit les relations femmes
hommes à égalité sont le fait aussi
d'autres reculs donc ce que je veux dire
là c'est que si y'a pas que l'islam
qu'on s'engage sur le contrôle de dérive
il faut le faire avec une manière un peu
plus plus large
on est un peu de hauteur j'ai bien roulé
je voudrais revenir aussi dire un mot un
peu de tous les travaux qu'il ya du côté
du sénat sur ces sujets ya notamment une
offensive de la droite sénatoriale avec
une commission denquête on le disait sur
la radio
lisa sion islamistes et les moyens de la
combattre la rapporteure et la sénatrice
et maire jacqueline eustache brinio il y
aussi la proposition de loi visant à
garantir dire la liste communautaire aux
élections municipales ou encore la
proposition de loi visant à garantir la
prééminence des lois de la république
il ya beaucoup d'accords sur ce plateau
mais est-ce que aussi la droite a
cherché à en faire un sujet politiciens
politique à l' approche des élections
oui et malia sont aussi avec sa prise de
parole oui mais ils sont pas forcément
les sols parfois vouloir le faire
abattre c'est la possibilité normal je
vais pas jeter la pierre à philippe
dallier
on va pas se fâcher tous les deux mais
très sincèrement je pense que celle où
ces projets de loi qui sont toujours un
petit peu sortis d'un coin de chapeau
parce que il ya eu un petit événement ne
sont jamais bons par contre philippe le
disais tout à l'heure les rapports
parlementaires eux sont d'excellente
qualité et c'est là-dessus qu'il faut
s'appuyer
parce qu'il y as après deux très vraies
propositions ne faisons pas des lois sur
des lois qui en fait ne sont pas
applicables en réalité parce que très
mal ficelé tu as mal conçus à voulait
pas dire de mal mais un petit tacle
quand même sur les normes proposition de
loi notamment proposé l'arbre est
d'ailleurs le monde on salue tous les
deux la qualité mais si effectivement
les rapports servent à calais les
armoires dans un eric quelconque il ya
un moment il faut trouver d'autres
moyens
quelqu'un a effectivement de discuter de
ces sujets dans l'hémicycle c'est de
déposer un moment donné une proposition
de loi et c'est ce que nous sommes
parfois amenés à faire voilà donc
j'espère simplement et je le redis que
enfin la société dans son ensemble
la classe politique peut-être certains
dans son ensemble va prendre ce sujet à
bras le corps
parce que il y a le feu à la maison dans
un certain nombre de territoires et pas
seulement dans quelques sites et il y a
des choses que même dans une vie comme
la mienne les pavillons sous bois
qui en seine-saint-denis est pas très
emblématique des problèmes de la
politique de la ville on voit des
comportements on voit des évolutions en
matière de commerce local
on voit un certain nombre de choses qui
me font dire que les choses s'étendent
il est temps que la république revienne
fortement que l'état reprenne le
contrôle
et là je suis d'accord avec gilbert
roger vous allez pouvoir les parents
bâtir les contrôles de qualité il faut
que tout ça soit effectivement mis en
action et à grande échelle
tout comme le contrôle je le dirai aussi
mais le contrôle de ces écoles privées
sans contrat d'association qui se crée
entre les coins de rue parfois il faut
qu'on obtienne des contrôles efficaces
de la part des services de l'éducation
nationale aura l'occasion en tout cas de
reparler de ce sujet parce qu'ils
allaient devoir faire des annonces ainsi
voilà vous pouvez revenir sur ce plateau
merci à tous les quêtes d'avoir
participé à ce débat alors que nous
sommes à une demi-heure des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement vous le
voyez d'ailleurs la salle des
conférences commencent à se remplir dans
30 minutes exactement
les sénateurs vont interpeller
l'exécutif vous pourrez ouvrir tous
vivre en direct et en intégralité parmi
les thèmes marquants de cette séance le
séparatisme islamique mais aussi la
sphère griveaux ou encore le coronavirus
qui pourrait impacter la production
mondiale de médicaments mais également
dans l'actualité la fermeture de la
centrale de fessenheim samedi edf va
initier l'arrêt du réacteur numéro un
l'arrêt complet de la centrale c'est
pour juin prochain une fin d'activité
qui s'inscrit dans le projet d' emmanuel
macron de ramener le nucléaire à 50 % du
mix énergétique d'ici 2035
comment reconvertir le site quel impact
pour l'emploi on va se poser toutes ces
questions mais d'abord retour sur la
fermeture de fessenheim avec aurélien
romano
la centrale de fessenheim va enfin
fermer le décret paru au journal
officiel le premier réacteur 900
mégawatts à eau pressurisée commencera à
être arrêter progressivement vendredi
soir le second réacteur sera arrêté le
30 juin
l'évacuation des combustibles usés va
s'étaler jusqu'à l'été 2000 23 tandis
que le démantèlement devrait aller
jusqu'en 2040 dans vingt ans celle
épilogue pour la plus vieille centrale
de france ouverte en 1977 est devenue un
serpent de mer de la vie politique
française
déjà en 2012 françois hollande et
nicolas sarkozy s'opposaient sur la
pertinence de la fermeture
je n'accepterai jamais la fermeture de
la centrale de fessenheim pour des
raisons politiciennes pour des calculs
politiciens
françois hollande avait fait de la
fermeture de fessenheim un objectif de
son quinquennat faisant de la vieille
centrale le symbole du tout nucléaire
français la centrale de fessenheim est
la plus ancienne de notre parc sera
fermée à la fin de l'année 2016 et
pourtant la fermeture n'a pu avoir lieu
avant la fin du mandat en 2017
c'est finalement emmanuel macron qui
scelle le sort de la centrale en 2018
dans le cadre de la programmation
pluriannuelle de l'énergie 14 réacteurs
de 900 mégawatts seront arrêtées d'ici à
2035 ce mouvement commencera à l'élite
et 2020 avec l'arrêt définitif des deux
réacteurs de fessenheim
cette fermeture pose la question du
devenir social du site matignon rey
assure aujourd'hui qu'un projet de
territoire a été finalisée en février
2019 avec les élus locaux et promet un
accompagnement pour tous les salariés
pourtant les syndicats sont inquiets car
2000 emplois directs et indirects sont
en jeu et on va parler de la fermeture
de fessenheim lors de ce face à face
avec bruno sido
bonjour vous êtes sénateur et l'ère de
la haute marne membres de l'office
parlementaire d'évaluation des choix
scientifiques et technologiques que vous
avez d'ailleurs présidé pendant un
certain temps
également sur ce plateau guillaume
gontard bonjour vous êtes sénateur
écologiste rattaché au groupe communiste
vice président de la commission de
l'aménagement du territoire et du
développement durable première question
pour vous guillaume gontard est ce que
vous saluer cette décision on l'a vu
dans ce reportage avait
beaucoup de promesses et finalement et
bien c'est l'exécutif actuel qui va
tenir cette promesse de la fermeture de
fessenheim premier réacteur samedi
deuxième réacteur juin prochain oui je
pense qu'on peut juste dire enfin parce
qu'effectivement il ya eu beaucoup
beaucoup de promesses avec françois
hollande et que enfin on arrive à cette
décision que je dirais quasi logique
puisqu'on est sur une centrale
ancien qui a plus que mon âge qui voilà
qui arrive et qui arrivés en bout de
course
et puis on a un projet est d'arriver à
50% de la part du nucléaire dont qui a
été repoussée d'ailleurs jusqu'à 2035
donc à un moment donné il fallait passer
aux actes donc je pense que pour une
fois que ce gouvernement en matière
environnement passe aux actes et de
manière concrète je peux que m'en
féliciter pour une assise doigt ce que
vous aussi vous saluer ce passage à
l'acte pour reprendre les mots de
guillaume gontard je note que ce que
françois hollande avait annoncé et n'a
pas réalisé
c'est le président de la république
actuel emmanuel macron qui le fait et en
même temps il dit qu'il faut préserver
cette filière nucléaire
parce que au fond on voit bien que il
n'y a pas d'autre solution pour faire
court oui je note quand même parce que
je ne suis pas tout à fait d'accord avec
vous que la centrale de fessenheim
venait de bénéficier de cet arrêt
décennal et de réflexion dépenses
importantes de la part d'edf vous dit
elle aurait pu prolonger son activité et
l'asm avait dit que c'était la centrale
la plus sûre de france puisque elle
venait elle venait d'être fait et que
cet instant et c'est celle-là qu'on
ferme franchement je vois pas la
cohérence c'est un symbole mais c'est un
symbole qui coûtent des centaines de
millions voilà c'est ça que je me pose
comme question
c'est l'argent du contribuable de
consommateurs et j'ai l'impression qu'on
se moque un peu du monde parce que ce
n'est pas une bonne décision
on sait très bien que le nucléaire à 50%
demeure en 2035
ça n'est pas faisable l'office
parlementaire de vous parliez tout à
l'heure nous l'avons démontré et c'était
trans partisan ça n'est pas faisable et
on va en discuter on va voir
tous et toutes ces tranches que qu'on
annonce ferme et décidée d'ici quelques
années
ça ne se fera pas ça n'est pas possible
tout simplement
guillaume gontard j'imagine que vous
n'êtes pas d'accord déjà danser c'est
évident que c'est tout à fait faisable
on a énormément d'eau regagner son nom
on a quand même une ppe qui a été qui a
été basée en a exactement qui a été
basée qui a été basée là-dessus donc
c'est pas faisable et on n'est pas tout
seul dans le monde et on a d'autres pays
qui qui arrive donc pour moi la question
ne se pose pas c'est tout à fait
faisable qu'on est face à une énergie
qu'on nous dit propres non seulement
elle ne l'est pas puisque on ne sait
toujours pas comment recycler les
déchets et que quand on va sur le centre
de bureau on prévoit d'en d'enfouir à
500 mètres sous terre des déchets et
j'irai mettre un peu la saleté sous le
tapis pour les générations futures ça me
paraît pas ça me paraît pas souhaitable
et qu'au contraire on a justement sur
les énergies renouvelables
là un vrai vecteur à la fois aussi de
développement économique notamment en
lien direct sur sur les territoires dont
je pense qu'au contraire l'avenir il est
bien sûr les énergies renouvelables
qu'il faut prendre acte qu'on arrive
avec des ddd solution nucléaire qui sont
qui sont en bout de course qui sont
dangereuses parce que on a quand même
des organismes qui nous ont alerté sur
la situation de fessenheim à la fois
pour les ressources en eau à la fois
pour la nappe phréatique à la fois sur
les risques de terrorisme et les risques
de sécurité
donc on avait aussi toute la question de
fukushima des liens sur le risque
sismique le bien sûr on a les risques
sismiques qu'on a on a on a eu quelques
tremblements de terre il ya peu de temps
et qui concernaient ma région
on a vu qu'on n'était pas à l'abri de
risques on a les risques d'inondation
également donc ils sont quand même assez
présent on sait qu'on est face à des
risques climatiques qui sauront de plus
en plus fort et de plus en plus
puissants donc je pense qu'il faut juste
être assez pragmatique et aborder
justement cette transition énergétique
notez qu'en tout cas bien l'exécutif se
félicite regarder ce communiqué du
premier min
cet événement annoncé est repoussé de
manière récurrente par les précédents
gouvernements marque la concrétisation
de l'engagement du président de la
république donc promesses tenues nous
dit edouard philippe
la professionnelle c'est tout de même un
saut dans l'inconnu pour vous à bruno
sido
je voudrais déjà noter que fessenheim
appartient à la france
en partie seulement puisque grosso modo
un tiers appartient à la suisse et à
l'allemagne
quand on me dit que certains pays
arrivent à fermer le nucléaire oui mais
il faut dire comment l'allemagne a
décidé elle avait décidé avant fukushima
fukushima avait décidé de relancer le
nucléaire
quinze jours avant 15 jours après madame
merkel qui est de la suite dans les
idées
décide d'arrêter la filière du tri peut
comprendre que ce soit très difficile à
défendre une opinion publique quand il
se passe
non mais je voudrais la changer en un
mois de toutes origines a été perdu
quand même non non attendez c'est pas un
accident nucléaire fukushima doucement
et en même temps on utilise le lignite
en relance ou d'unité on importe de
l'électricité ce qui d'origine nucléaire
pour la suisse on ferme le nucléaire
très bien que font-ils
ils ont de l'hydraulique avec des
steppes des stations de transfert le
pompage est naturellement on remonte
l'eau la nuit avec l électricité
l'électricité nucléaire française donc
voilà c'est un peu disons cynique comme
politique et la france la france
finalement et bonne mer dans tout cela
parce que pour bien dire ben écoutez
vous voulez pas du nucléaire on vous
entend pas alors comme il faut en vendre
et c'est très bien bon on exporte de
l'électricité mais en attendant nous
dire que d'aider d'autres pays y arrive
non il ne reste pas sans doute hélas pas
vrai en tout cas la décision maintenant
aller prises envers ce procès un symbole
sur la praye fessenheim ça pose quand
même des difficultés je le disais c'est
quand même un saut dans l'inconnu
guillaume bon tard et par exemple il va
y avoir aussi des difficultés dans le
démantèlement des charges et le coeur du
réacteur vidanger les circuits des
pontes démonter les parties non
radioactive
tout ça ce sont des opérations risquées
compliqué l'immédiat après fessenheim
c'est pas du tout simple guillaume
gontard blessure et c'est d'ailleurs une
des conséquences justement de cette
énergie de cergy
clair c'est qu'on sait a encore pas
justement comment démanteler un une
telle une telle installation donc
effectivement ça va être énormément de
travail alors d'un côté on peut s'en
réjouir parce que quand on se dit qu'est
ce que vont faire les salariés qui sont
dans le nucléaire c'est vrai il eu une
une manière de pouvoir réciter à une
partie de salariés et de donner du
travail sur la reconversion de ses sites
de ses sites nucléaires
mais c'est vrai que c'est une vraie
question on a lancé une énergie un
dispositif dans les années 60-70 en
disant ne vous inquiétez pas dans dans
les 20 ans qui vont venir on trouvera
une solution pour les déchets on en est
aujourd'hui à n'avoir toujours pas de
solution si ce n'est l'enfouir sous
terre
vous parlez à du volet économique
effectivement puisque la centrale de
fessenheim a été jusqu'à 850 agents edf
300 salariés de sous-traitants
travaillant sur le site mille emplois
indirects pour des retombées fiscales de
14,3 millions d'euros ça c'est quand la
centrale tournait à plein la question
qui se pose aujourd'hui effectivement
c'est que vont devenir ces salariés quel
va être le coût économique de ce
démantèlement bruno sido
alors avant de parler de cette casse
sociale bien entendu je voudrais corps
social casse sociale c'est clair bah oui
quand même tous ses angles et précisé
que edf s'est très bien comment
démanteler les centrales nucléaires
c'est une question de temps à quai il
faut inventer 0
mais à quel coût shoah par exemple étant
en cours de démantèlement non brennilis
et en cours de démantèlement
son démantèlement d'ailleurs été arrêté
à cause des écologistes pour des raisons
purement administratives
c'est assez curieux m'enfin passons
alors maintenant parlons de la casse
sociale effectivement je note que la cgt
contre la fermeture de cette centrale
nucléaire
il va falloir les recaser tous ces gens
là se retrouvent du travail alors dit
mais on va faire de fessenheim est
finalement l'icône du démantèlement cela
on va faire des centres d'apprentissage
démantèlement que ceux des restaurants
on verra en attendant un projet la suite
mais franchement quand on a deux mines
plus de 2000 milliards d'euros de dette
est ce que vous croyez qu'on a les
moyens de se payer comme ça pour pour le
symbole fermer une centrale nucléaire
qui ne demande qu'à tourner encore
pendant 10 ans sont sans aucun problème
franchement on a un comportement assez
curieux en france on a l'impression que
l'argent ne compte pas eux qu'on se
moque du contribuable bien entendu et
qu'on fait de la casse sociale c'est pas
grave moi je suis pas d'accord est-ce
que j'ai que l'état a correctement mener
cette transition économique pour
l'instant je voudrais revenir parce
qu'on dit le justement le coût du
nucléaire
le déficit etc on voit bien justement
que le coup le coup de ce2 ce2 se
nucléaire de cette de cette énergie
c'est devenu l'énergie la plus chère non
j électrique jeu marc la production
d'énergie c'est évident non et j'en ai
et j'en ai pour preuve c'est que on a le
fameux projet hercules 2 du gouvernement
et qui nous dit quoi
vu la situation du nucléaire il va faire
pour renationaliser en général on
nationalise plutôt les pertes 1 à 10 par
contre les énergies renouvelables qui
eux ramène de l'argent
donc je pense qu'en fait il ya juste un
changement de paradigme et qu'il faut
savoir où on va et comment il me semble
que là il ya un vrai enjeu effectivement
sur savoir la place de l'état la place
de la stratégie énergétique de notre
pays et notamment remettre la main aussi
sur les énergies les années les énergies
renouvelables franchement quand le
banlieusard prend son train le matin à
6h45 6h30 c'est un train électrique
il ne cherche pas à savoir s'il ya du
vent ou si elle lumière il présentera
une doit arriver à l'heure au travail
je veux dire par là que l'énergie
renouvelable actuelle je parle pas de
l'hydroélectricité mais de l'éolien du
photovoltaïque
ce sont des nerfs des énergies qui ne
sont pas à leur coup pourquoi pas ce que
c'est on avait que ça il faudrait
prévoir les périodes où il n'y a pas de
vins où il n'ya pas de lumière et par
conséquent on estime aujourd'hui que ces
60 euros sont ceux de le mégawatheure le
mégawattheure à vrai dire c'est le
double aussi on voulait si cette
électricité assumer 24 heures sur 24 le
service qu'on attendait donc voilà il
faut quand même bien le savoir ne pas de
ne pas dire que l'éolien et au même coût
que le nucléaire c'est faux à un tout
dernier mot très rapidement tous les
deux sur camel l'état de la filière
nucléaire française puisque vous avez
commencé à en parler mais il ya aussi
une forme de crise un peu la tente
on le voit avec les difficultés du
chantier de l'est
r les projets de scission d'edf on est
calme dans un moment compliqué pour la
finale oui parce que havas liront sa
personne n'avait pas construite
centrales nucléaires depuis une
vingtaine d'années et on avait perdu de
savoir-faire tout simplement et on le
paye mais c'est de savoir faire
mécanique je veux pas dire c'est pas la
technologie nucléaire qui est en cause
mais c'est le béton c'est la ferraille
s'est s'était tant qu'on ait perdu le
savoir faire quand même parce qu'on a
quelques centrales qui sont encore en
fonctionnement il vaut mieux qu'on sache
encore faire et comment et comment les
gérer
non je pense qu'on est dans une filière
qui est kaki qui enfin 2 en fin de vie
enfin 2 en fin de course je pense qu'il
faut maintenant mettre nos
investissements sur autre chose et
regarder regarder l'avenir en face
effectivement il va y avoir et ça va pas
se faire tout seul un passé à 50% en
c'est un réacteur parents qui va qui va
s'arrêter on est quand même sur un
rythme tout à fait faisable
maintenant il faut il faut y aller et
passer à autre chose voilà merci
beaucoup en tout cas d'avoir participé
tous les deux à ce face à face à je me
rappelle donc le premier réacteur de
fessenheim va s'arrêter samedi prochain
tout de suite on va rejoindre alexandre
poussard vous êtes avec bernard jomier
sénateur écologiste de paris
on va parler bien d'un des thèmes qui va
marquer cette séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
et bien la sphère griveaux et puis
l'arrivée d' agnès buzyn dans la
campagne parisienne
effectivement l'arrivée d'agnès busin
dans la campagne parisienne
tout d'abord bernard jaume i comment
vous avez perçu ce choix d'agnès busan
de quitter son ministère des solidarités
de la santé alors qu'elle avait des
dossiers très importants comme la crise
du coronavirus également la crise de
l'hôpital un peu surprenant parce que le
premier ministre dit c'était une très
bonne ministre de la santé ce sera une
très bonne mère de paris mais si c'était
une très bonne mine is de la santé il
devait la garder ou alors ça révèle une
hiérarchie une priorité dans les choix
qui est un peu surprenante le parti
présidentiel cherche à tout prix à
gagner des villes plutôt qu à bien
gouverner le pays
après moi c'est pas l'analyse que j'en
ai je pense que ça n'a pas été une très
bonne ministre de la santé elle avait en
charge le dossier des retraites lh2 le
dossier de l'hôpital public et on voit
que sur ces deux plans là cette année
alors désormais elle se lance dans la
campagne municipale parisienne c'est
plutôt une bonne chose qu'une une
ministre d'envergure du gouvernement
participent à cette campagne municipale
à paris vous savez quand un jour j on ne
pense même pas être simplement
conseiller municipal dans une ville et
que deux jours après on dit qu'on veut
être maire de cette ville
c'est quand même un tempo qui est
surprenant après qu est ce qu a divinis
agnès buzyn depuis qu'elle est entrée en
campagne elle a écarté tous les projets
structurants de son prédécesseur de
benjamin griveaux elle dit je serai
bienveillante donc cette bienveillance
dont elle n'a pas fait preuve
visiblement on le voit vis-à-vis des
personnels des hôpitaux publics
vis-à-vis des français qui sont inquiets
pour leur retraite
elle dit qu'elle apportera à paris donc
c'est une campagne d' attitude et une
campagne de contenu ça c'est edouard
balladur 1 il ya 20 ou 30 ans selon la
fois la messe et une campagne à la
edouard balladur c'est d'ailleurs une
campagne d'attitude
une campagne qui n'est pas une campagne
de contenu et politiquement ça ne mène
nulle part et dans cette élection à
paris justement est ce que rachida dati
sera là jacques chirac de l'élection
parisienne mais rachida elle fait le
monte dans les sondages rachida dati
elle porte un projet qui n'est pas le
mien
elle veut rouvrir les voies sur berge
voiture elle ne veut plus concert
logements sociaux mais il faut constater
qu'elle porte un projet qui a du contenu
c'est ça la vie politique s'est proposé
aux habitants d'une ville de véritables
options alors agnès buzyn quitte son
ministère de la santé avec je le disais
des dossiers importants notamment la
réforme des retraites aujourd'hui la cgt
claque la porte de la conférence de
financement du système de retraite
est ce que cette conférence de
financement est vouée à l'échec bah
merci agnès buzyn d'avoir laissé le
dossier dans cet état là on est dans une
confusion totale des parlementaires qui
doivent se prononcer alors que les
questions de financement sont pas réglés
les partenaires sociaux auxquels on
demande de régler la question du
financement
alors qu'ils ne connaissent pas
exactement le contenu de la réforme et
les paramètres et que le gouvernement ne
trône ne met pas tout sur la table quand
vous demandez aux gens de travailler
autour d'une table dans de telles
conditions
l'échec est programmé il faut ajouter
que les délais sont bien trop court on
ne peut pas régler ces questions d'ici
mois d'avril merci beaucoup bernard
jomier d'avoir répondu à mes questions
alors que nous sommes à un quart d'heure
du début des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
merci beaucoup à alexandre et même à
onze minutes du début de ces questions
d'actualité au gouvernement vous l'avez
dit par mille
question il y aura des questions sur
cette affaire benjamin griveaux et les
répercussions pour l'exécutif pour en
parler je suis avec frédéric sinclair
bonjour bonjour vous êtes politologue
rappelle le nom de votre dernier livre
la droite face à l'islam aux éditions
salvator d'abord votre regard sur et
bien ce coup de tonnerre dans la
campagne parisienne le retrait de
benjamin griveaux l'irruption d'agnès
busin à paris est ce que pour vous ça a
rebâti ou pas rebattu les cartes pour la
république en marche
oui indéniablement il ya une crise et la
crise rebat les cartes de facto ensuite
on avait un personnage qui peinait à
devenir emblématique il représentait mal
l'image de l'air m
à paris on attendait finalement
quelqu'un peut-être de un peu plus
urbain un peu plus écolo un peu plus
projeter vers l'avenir
on a une personnalité qui était
finalement assez bien insérés dans l
hérault m oui mais qui ne montraient pas
le chemin quelque part et donc qui peiné
face à rachida dati a l'hidalgo à
s'imposer il y avait la personnalité
puis la campagne de benjamin briois
était assez calamiteuse avec une
succession de crises de suite de
difficultés de propositions qui ont paru
parfois extravagantes tout à fait la
gare de l'est et les cent mille euros
pour à pouvoir acquérir son appartement
d'ailleurs deux propositions sur
laquelle agnès buzyn a tout de suite dit
non je ne ferai pas elle a eu raison
et pour vous c'est une meilleure
candidate alors je pense
qu'effectivement il faut jauger aussi le
temps restant qui est extrêmement court
et puis le l'image qu'elle assemble on
les fait dans les sondages est
d'ailleurs qui sont parus
on commence à paraître aujourd'hui
exactement mais mais je pense qu'en
terme d'image de façon absolue il me
semble qu'elles qu'elles génèrent
davantage de sympathie que benjamin
griveaux ensuite de toute façon face à
ce qui s'était passé et aux images qui
sont parus sur les réseaux sociaux font
vidéos qui sont pas sur les eaux sociaux
il semblait impossible de tenir la
barque pour les rues m il fallait une
solution de remplacement il me semble
que ce choix n'est pas le pire alors que
pensez vous justement de cette irruption
dans la vie publique de ces fed
vie privée des faits qui étaient
moralement condamnable mais pas illégaux
pour autant ils font irruption sur la
toile et voilà votre campagne est finie
oui j'allais dire rien neuf sous le
soleil
ouais c'est la méthode qui change
finalement qui devient de plus en plus
numérique
elle touche à peu près toutes les stars
américaines
oui il ya une américanisation de la vie
politique même certains complètement
après tout fin en france on a toujours
accepté que le président de la
république soit infidèle fin ce n'était
pas un problème en soi et là on ya aussi
le choc des réseaux sociaux le choc de
l'image là ça serait passé autrement
c'est-à-dire qu'elles auraient fait
irruption de manière anonyme sur les
réseaux sociaux
on aurait dit basse et c'est un petit
peu comme d'habitude la nouveauté c'est
7 7 7 artistes puisque c'est ainsi qu'il
faut le qualifier cet artiste russe qui
a demandé l'asile qui apprennent un ski
qui a demandé l'asile en france et qui
est finalement un militant plus que un
artiste et un artiste militant il a oui
c'est ça il faut insister sur le
militant et parce que quand on regarde
son son art finalement ça a été vraiment
une opposition à poutine en règle en
russie donc on voit bien aujourd'hui que
c'est ça qui fait question et c'est ça
qui permet aujourd'hui à arm et
notamment emmanuel macron de dénoncer
encore les ingérences russe dans les
affaires politiques français ça donne du
grain à moudre à l'exécutif un refrain
qu'on avait effectivement entendu
pendant la campagne présidentielle
d'emmanuel macro alors le problème pour
l'exécutif sait que agnès buzyn était en
charge de dossiers importants de
dossiers urgents les retraites la crise
de l'hôpital et en plus de cela
l'épidémie de coronavirus elle avait
d'ailleurs écarter une candidature 48
heures avant de dire que finalement elle
était candidate d'un angle d'attaqué
facile pour l'opposition
oui et puis vous vous rappelez qu'elle
avait déjà été pressenti avant natale et
l'oiseau pour les européens cela veut
dire que dans les cartons et les rues m
agnès buzyn apparemment elle a un statut
particulier alors est ce qu'on a envie
de s'en défaire ou est ce qu'on a envie
de la mettre en avant je laisserais
chacun juge
mais en tout cas ce qui est certain
c'est que il y à une communication
autour de ces possibles sorties du
gouvernement récurrentes qui est
problématique
alors parmi et les dossiers chauds que
agnès buzyn avait en charge
il y avait notamment celui des retraites
on vient d'apprendre que la cgt va se
retirer de la conférence de financement
est ce que c'est pour vous une surprise
et puis surtout est-ce que ça prépare
pas le retour de l'âge pivot tout ça
alors je je pense pas que il y autre
chose dans la tête de l arm et de la
droite
française qu'un recul de l'âge de la
retraite de toute façon donc oui on se
dirige de toute façon vers un
allongement de la durée de cotisation
c'est certain donc après qu'on l'appelle
âges pivots ou que on recadre retarde
l'âge légal ça reviendrait à peu près où
il avait été suspendu disons dans le
cadre des négociations et d'un philippe
a dit si vous n'arrivez pas à vous
entendre il va certainement revenir là
on y est comme ça on y est et puis on
savait de toute façon que la cgt
claquerait la porte parce que la cgt
c'est un principe de vie elle claque la
porte
alors quel regard justement portez-vous
pour le coup sûr la bataille qui est en
train de se dérouler à l'assemblée la
bataille parlementaire pour vous qu'est
ce qui a mené à cette situation c'est
notre situation d'obstruction
parlementaire l'opposition ou bien aussi
le gouvernement a sa part de
responsabilité il s'arc boutait aussi
sur son calendrier
je ne crois pas la part de
responsabilité du gouvernement en
matière de pratique
je sais même pas comment la qualifier
parce qu'à la fois elle est habituel ces
milliers d'amendements en parler du jeu
exactement
et puis en même temps on a l'impression
que c'est une obstruction qui est qui
est factice parce qu'elle ne fait jamais
plié aucun gouvernement
elle les pousse à la faute c'est tout
c'est la faute à 2,49 exactement la
faute ce sera 40
merci beaucoup frédéric saint clair pour
tous les éclairages on vous retrouve
après les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement mais pour l'heure on va se
rendre salle des conférences se trouvait
alexandre poussard avec philippe bas le
président de la commission des lois vous
allez revenir avec lui sur un sujet qui
va être abordé cet après-midi ce sujet
c'est le séparatisme islamistes oui le
séparatisme islamiste où le
communautarisme c'est selon philippe
bach comment vous avez accueilli ces
premières mesures d' emmanuel macron
pour lutter contre le communautarisme je
voudrais que c'est dégagé une espèce de
consensus républicain
voyez par exemple hier le nouveau
président du conseil supérieur du culte
musulman a fait une déclaration très
intéressante pour dire que le
communautarisme est contraire aux
valeurs de fraternité des musulmans et
il a ainsi montré toute la différence
qu'il faut faire entre l'islam qui est
une religion que la france respecte
parce que nous avons la laïcité et les
prétentions politiques des islamistes
qui revendique le communautarisme
le président de la république est allé
dans le même sens et je ne peux que
l'approuver quand ils rappellent comme
il l'a fait que la loi de la religion ne
peut jamais être supérieure à la loi de
la république
et c'est précisément ce qui me paraît
essentiel aujourd'hui c'est de rétablir
nos repères de rétablir nos références
pour que comme nous le proposons avec
bruno retailleau avec hervé marseille
avec beaucoup de collègues nous
puissions inscrire tant que plus
personne n'hésite dans la constitution
de la république que nul individu ou
nuls groupe ne peut se prévaloir de ses
croyances ou de ses origines pour
s'exonérer du respect de la règle
commune et quant à emmanuel macron
souhaite et bien d'avoir des imams
uniquement formée en france c'est une
mesure suffisante selon lui on va pas
discuter
semaine après semaine de mesures qui
peuvent se surajouter je crois qu'il
faut être clair que la référence soit
clair qu'à ce soit clair dans les
mairies dans les piscines dans les
écoles dans les hôpitaux dans les
bureaux dans les ateliers dans les
services publics dans les transports
dans les centres de loisirs dans les
centres sportifs
nul ne peut se prévaloir de ses origines
pour échapper au respect de la règle
commune un point c'est tout
la république ne l'a jamais proclamé
dans ses textes fondamentaux
elle doit le faire pour que nul ne
puisse ignorer alors emmanuel macron
propose des mesures précises concrètes
vous
vous proposer directement et bien de
réviser la constitution pour lutter
contre le communautarisme avec une
proposition de loi constitue
constitutionnel il faut toucher à se
constituer à cette constitution pardon
pour résoudre ce problème
c'est l'acte le plus important qu'on
puisse faire il faut que pas un français
ne puisse ignorer cette trail qu'on
sorte des hésitations actuelles en
sortent des discours et des
dissertations qu'on sorte de la
sémantique et qu'on rentre dans une
action qui a besoin d'être fédérer
derrière un principe forts proclamait
haut niveau le plus élevé de notre droit
dans la république
très bien merci beaucoup philippe bas et
vous avez vous allez d'ailleurs
interrogé le premier ministre sur ce
sujet du séparatisme
on va se rendre dans la tribune de
presse de l'hémicycle du sénat vous
retrouver alice bardot à l'iss
quel va être le programme de ces
questions d'actualité au gouvernement eh
bien sans surprise alexandre d'oka les
sénateurs vont interpeller le
gouvernement sur les mesures annoncées
hier par emmanuel macron à pour lutter
contre le séparatisme islamistes alors
deux questions à ce sujet et dont une à
l'ouverture de la séance alors pour
rappel le président a notamment annoncé
un plus grand contrôle des financements
étrangers des mosquées ou encore la fin
progressive des idées imams détachées
pour qu'ils soient formés en france
alors hier soir le président du groupe
lr bruno retailleau a réagi à ces
annonces pour dénoncer des mesures très
faible dans un instant philippe bach
dont convient de l'entendre pour le
groupe lr
interpellera le gouvernement à ce sujet
ce ne sera pas le cas des socialistes
mais ce matin dans la matinale de public
sénat
leur chef de file patrick kanner a lui
aussi déploré des annonces je cite assez
light
alors petit rappel le sénat planche
beaucoup sur le sujet une commission d'
enquête sur la radicalisation islamiste
a été créé plusieurs propositions de loi
ont été déposées
alors cette séance de questions
d'actualité devrait être également avoir
l'alluré d'un baptême du feu pour
olivier ferrand leurs remplaçants
d'agnès busan à la santé le départ
précipité de l'ancien ministre pour la
course à la mairie de paris en pleine
réforme des retraites et alors que le
bilan de l'épidémie de coronavirus ne
cesse de s'alourdir fera l'objet de
questions à droite comme à gauche de
l'hémicycle son successeur ex-député lrm
et ancien socialiste va devoir répondre
à des questions de la gauche donc sur
des dossiers chauds du moment
le dossier des retraites évidemment
dernier rebondissement en date la cgt
qui vient de claquer la porte de la
conférence de financement autre dossier
le corona virus tout de suite donc les
questions au gouvernement la cloche
vient de sonner
nous n'avons pas reçu d'observation y'en
a t'il en séance je n'en vois pas il est
donc adoptée sous les réserves d'usagé
ce premier ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues nord d' ordre du jour appelle
les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
notre séance et retransmise en direct
sur public sénat et sur notre site
internet
chacun d'entre vous sera attentif au
respect du temps de parole et au respect
des uns et des autres la parole est à
notre collègue madame nathalie delattre
pour le groupe du rassemblement
démocratique et social européen
vous avez la parole mes chers collègues
merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre mes chers
collègues hier le président de la
république s'est rendu à mulhouse afin
d'évoquer un sujet sensible la lutte
contre les communautarismes où selon la
nouvelle sémantique le séparatisme
religieux
cette prise de parole était attendue et
elle est salutaire car oui la menace que
la radicalisation religieuse fait peser
sur notre modèle républicain et laïque
du vivre ensemble est réel
la commission d'enquêté sénatoriale sur
la radicalisation islamiste que j'ai
l'honneur de présider aux côtés de la
rapporteure jacqueline eustache brinio
mais toujours la convergence des points
de vue sur la gravité de la situation
par delà les constats partisans il est
effectivement urgent d'agir
mais pour atteindre les objectifs la
question des moyens qui seront consacrés
moyens financiers et humains ainsi que
la détermination à chaque niveau de
s'impliquer dans ce combat sera
déterminante
ce sont des réponses concrètes qu'il
nous faut apporter aux situations
quotidiennes qui s'opposent aux communes
aux écoles aux universités aux
associations aux fédérations sportives
aux hôpitaux et la liste est encore
longue pour autant monsieur le premier
ministre
j'ai eu cette désagréable impression
hier que le président de la république
s'engager dans la voie de solution par
un islam de france
et non malgré les tentatives peu
probantes de ses prédécesseurs il y
avait effectivement un islam en france
pratiqué par des milliers de musulmans
dans le respect des lois de notre
république et de la laïcité
la laïcité est là pour protéger les
croyants comme les non croyants des
islamistes islamistes que la république
ne doit donc pas institutionnaliser
ainsi le ministre de l'intérieur de
préciser ce matin sur france inter qu'il
était prêt à accorder des moyens aux
religions loin des principes actuels de
notre loi de 1905
cela nous paraît dangereux aussi
monsieur le premier ministre
quels sont vos véritables mans les
moyens que vous allez à louer pour
mettre en oeuvre les annonces égrainé
hier afin d'apporter des réponses fortes
aux menaces qui pèsent tant à la fois
sur les français de confession musulmane
que sur notre unité nationale
je vous remercie pour vos réponses la
parole est au ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur christophe que stonehenge avez
la parole monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs sciatique peur madame la
sénatrice le séparatisme c'est la
volonté de quelques-uns de s'éloigner
des valeurs de la république pir de
considérer que les valeurs de la brique
devrait s'effacer devant d'autres
valeurs des influences étrangères ou des
influences ou des décisions religieuse
qui s'imposeraient aux valeurs de la
république
évidemment il nous faut et je sais
qu'ici tout le monde est totalement
engagée sera totalement mobilisée lutter
contre ce séparatisme l'a qui existe et
vous y travaillez actuellement dans le
cadre de la commission que vous pilotez
qui existe au delà des grandes villes au
delà de certains quartiers qui peut
exister dans la ruralité et nous le
savons et vous le savez tous ici le pr
marc et puis qui hier a présenté un plan
d'action et le premier volet de ce plan
d'action un plan d'action qui se
construit sur les questions et les
enjeux de sécurité
tout d'abord et c'est la politique que
du moment que nous menons dans le cas de
la reconquête républicaine et en
particulier dans 15 quartiers dont nous
avons présenté le bilan d'activités j'y
reviendrai si nous avons le temps qui
montre combien on nous lever nous devons
tous ensemble lutter contre
l'organisation de ce pass séparatisme
sert des écosystèmes qui se créent et
qui au fond cherche à éviter à esquiver
la république le deuxième axe est la
lutte contre les influences étrangères
le président de la république l'a abordé
longuement hier le troisième axe est de
redonner corps
la promesse républicaine dont on sait
aussi qu'il y à un déterminisme social
un sentiment d'échec qui peut conduire
aussi vers des formes de radicalisation
et donc il nous faut sur ces sujets être
totalement mobilisés madame la sénatrice
je voudrais vous rassurer
nul ici et moi le premier ne souhaite
donner des moyens pour reprendre votre
expression occulte le principe même de
la loi de 1905 doit être défendue je le
défend activement
il n'est pas question de mettre en place
des financements publics pour financer
les cultes quel qu'il soit le principe
de la laïcité c'est le faire en sorte
que chacun puisse aussi avoir le droit
de croire avec les moyens de croire et
nous devons contrôler cela le président
a fixé à exclure à nouveau dans quelques
jours puis globalement nous présenterons
un plan d'action sur lequel je suis
convaincu que nous nous retrouverons
tous pour faire en sorte que le
séparatisme recul et que la république
soit reconquise mètre carré par mètre
carré par tous est nécessaire
merci la parole est à notre collègue
marie noëlle lienemann pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen et
écologistes avaient la parole mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'économie
madame la secrétaire d'état la
directrice générale de renault a indiqué
vendredi ne pas avoir de tabou sur des
fermetures de sites en france
cette déclaration suscite un légitime
émoi dans le pays des difficultés chez
renault il y en a certes mais le groupe
a cumulé 10 milliards d'euros de
bénéfices pendant les quatre dernières
années et verser le tiers de ses
bénéfices en dividende aux actionnaires
pour 2019 se sont encore 312 millions
d'euros de dividendes qui seront versés
on peut s'intéresser s'interroger sur la
pertinence de ses choix
si la chute du marché automobile en
europe est réel celle-ci impact tout
particulièrement et plus
particulièrement
renault plus que d'autres pourquoi
premièrement parce que le groupe n'a pas
vu si suffisamment pour présenter deux
nouvelles gammes et surtout pour engager
un niveau nécessaire engagé un niveau
nécessaire la transition technologique
et écologique indispensable c'est
désormais l'urgence absolue en
produisant comme le demande
des organisations syndicales des
véhicules multi énergie hybride ou
électrique
deuxièmement la direction de renault a
fait des choix défavorable à la france
il ya une baisse de 43% de la
fabrication française
dans le groupe renault depuis 2004
délocalisation de l'hexagone et
particulièrement pour les productions
les plus attractives celles qui se
vendent le mieux
l'état actionnaire a manifestement été
défaillant en tout cas désormais il doit
veiller à ce que ce mouvement soit
inversée et que des investissements de
modernisation soient réalisés dans tous
les sites français et que l'on regagne
ainsi des capacités de production le
préalable est de refaire refuser toute
fermeture de site pour engager la
mutation et la reconquête de l'emploi
madame la ministre monsieur le maire a
déclaré que vous serez cuse qu'il serait
vigilant
je lui demande comment sera-t-il
efficace car pour garantir le maintien
des silos pour maintenir l'emploi
réorienter la stratégie industrielle et
consolidait la souveraineté économique
du pays
pour vous répondre la parole est à
madame agnès pannier rue nash et
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'économie et des finances au nab la
ministre merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice lienemann vous avez
raison renault est confrontée à des
résultats en forte baisse ils sont
négatifs cette année qui sont
emblématiques des défis que traverse
aujourd'hui la filière automobile ces
défis cheveux les rappeler parce qu'ils
sont importants
il ya trois défis structurels le premier
c'est la transition énergétique et
sachez que renault a massivement investi
dans cette direction notamment dans la
transition vers le moteur électrique
le deuxième défi c'est celui du véhicule
connecté qui va amener
justement à proposer d'autres services
et peut-être avoir d'autres acteurs
rentrer sur ce marché et concurrencer
ces acteurs historiques et puis le
troisième défi c'est le véhicule
autonome
ces trois défis il impose des
investissements massifs et c'est ce que
vous voyez dans les comptes de renault
c'est à dire que ces investissements il
consomme l'argent qui a été gagné et
même au delà puisque nous avons une
trajectoire de cash négatif le contexte
conjoncturel ne facilite pas les choses
baisse ralentissement ni aux états unis
et en europe baisse en chine et c'est
dans ce contexte que le gouvernement
accompagne la filière autonome
automobile je veux rappeler les
décisions qui ont été prises le contrat
stratégique de filière signé en mai 2018
le la réunion que nous avons fait le dès
le 2 décembre dernier pour faire en
sorte de préparer 2020 avec deux mesures
importantes une mesure pour accompagner
la diversification la sous traitance 50
millions d'euros destiné à cette
diversification est également destinée à
supporter de l'année 2020 les
difficultés possibles de financement de
l'automobile et de sa sous traitance à
hauteur de plus de 200 millions d'euros
et puis la mission que nous avons confié
hervé guyot sur la compétitivité
l'automobile en france et la
consolidation de certaines filières je
pense à la fonderie à lafarge heures
pour conclure oui nous serons très
vigilants aux côtés de renault et nous
avons déjà les instruments pour
accompagner ces transitions si la parole
est à notre collègue marie pierre de la
gontrie pour le groupe socialiste et
républicain
la parole
ma question s'adresse au premier
ministre monsieur le premier ministre il
ya cinq jours
la république en marche a connu un crash
politique anéantissant son dispositif
électoral à paris avec le président de
la république vous avez alors désigné en
48 heures la ministre des solidarités de
la santé comme candidate de substitution
improvisé
curieuse décision en plein chaos de la
réforme des retraites de crise sans fin
de l'hôpital public de risque de
pandémie du coronavirus vous décidez je
dois changer de ministre votre
gouvernement ne cesse de nous surprendre
par sa légèreté parfois par sa vulgarité
comme celle de votre ministre de
l'intérieur ce matin à l'égard de notre
collègue député olivier faure nous
attendons sur ce point nous attendons
sur ce point votre cas damnation
solennelle naufrage de la réforme des
retraites
11 - de grève des personnels
hospitaliers démission collective des
chefs de service par son tel report du
plan grand âge fermetures de maternités
le bilan de madame butin qui prétendait
vouloir réenchanter l'hôpital ressemble
aujourd'hui un champ de ruines
donc monsieur le premier ministre de
deux choses l'une prétendez-vous sourd
et aveugle et contre toute réalité que
madame busin fut une excellente ministre
comme vous l'indiquez hier auquel cas
son départ marque une désinvolture qui
frise pour certains le mépris pour les
politiques publiques ou bien
partagez-vous en réalité le constat des
français et avez vous saisi l'occasion
pour acter son départ du gouvernement le
xviie ou xviiie de mi-2017 monsieur le
premier ministre la france mérite que
vous privilégier l'intérêt général
plutôt que l'intérêt partisan
nos concitoyens attendent donc votre
réponse bon vous répondre la parole est
à monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice
merci de cette question formulée sur un
ton très ferme et qui travaillent ou
plus exactement qui indique pardon elle
ne trahit rien mais lundi qu à la fois
peut-être votre incompréhension de la
décision que j'ai proposé au président
de la république
peut-être aussi mais je dis peut-être
indique-t-elle une forme de surprises et
et qui sait de fébrilité par rapport à
cette décision
[Musique]
je ne fais pas partie de ceux qui
pensent que les élections sont joués
d'avancé et je peux même vous dire
madame la sénatrice peut-être est-ce que
cela vous est arrivé également que en la
matière j'ai cotisé pour voir voyons
donc
donc je veux répondre à votre à votre
question au fond de la façon la plus
simple possible
j'ai dit et je redirai toujours que
agnès buzyn était une remarquable
ministre de la santé remarquable
vous avez le droit de pas être d'accord
mais j'ai le droit de vous donner mon
avis remarquable par sa connaissance des
dossiers
remarquable par sa technicité
remarquable par son humanité
oui madame la sénatrice remarquable par
son humanité
remarquable par la façon et vous le
savez parfaitement dont elle a eu vallée
des dossiers redoutablement complexe
dossier dossier madame la sénatrice dont
vous m'accorderez qu'ils ne sont pas nés
avec sa désignation
mais qu'il venait souvent de loin les
difficultés du système médical les
difficultés du monde hospitalier ne sont
pas nés il ya deux ans il faut y
répondre
chacun essaie de faire de son mieux et
je veux dire combien madame la ministre
agnès buzyn a été en la matière engagé
compétente est remarquable elle a choisi
de s'engager dans un combat politique
elle a eu raison elle a eu raison
madame la sénatrice et je suis surpris
madame la sénatrice
je suis surpris madame la sénatrice
qu'un certain nombre de ceux qui parfois
dans cet hémicycle et souvent à
l'extérieur reproché à tel ou tel membre
du gouvernement sa prétendue des
connexions avec le monde réel
puisse aujourd'hui s'étonner de ce que
une ministres choisissent d'aller
défendre ses idées et son projet dans
une élection municipale pour la roulette
et madame la sénatrice et je constate je
constate que les sénateurs parisiens ont
l'air virulent ça me surprend vous allez
voir tout va bien se passer pour la
remplacer madame la sénatrice
j'ai proposé au président de la
république de nommer ministre des
solidarités et de la santé olivier
ferrand
vous le connaissez c'est un député
compétent qui a la triple
caractéristiques qui ne me semble pas
inutile en la matière d'être à la fois
médecin hospitalier rapporteur général
de la commission des affaires sociales
est par ailleurs bon spécialiste du
dossier des retraites puisqu'il était
rapporteur du projet de loi organique en
matière de réforme des retraites
autrement autrement dit madame la
sénatrice
il me paraît avoir les compétences dont
nous avons besoin pour faire face aux
dossiers que vous avez cités qui sont
des dossiers importants délicat sur
lesquels il est déjà un excellent
connaisseur et sur lesquels vous aurez
l'occasion de voir j'en suis sûr madame
la sénatrice et vous n'en serais pas
surprise qu'il est parfaitement
compétent et parfaitement efficace
autrement dit madame la sénatrice il y à
des élections municipales et c'est tant
mieux
le débat va avoir lieu il aura lieu au
cours de ces élections les électeurs le
trancherons et c'est très bien ainsi
merci madame de la gontrie
madame que carbone s'il vous plaît
monsieur le premier ministre je regrette
tout d'abord que vous n'ayez pas cru
devoir condamner les propos
inacceptables de christophe castaner ce
matin à la radio dont acte sur les
propos que vous avez tenus à l'instant
j'indique puisque vous louer le talent
de madame busin que c'est bien elle qui
a accepté que les nouvelles exonérations
de cotisations de sécurité sociale que
le gouvernement a consenti et qui a
plongé le déficit de la sécurité sociale
en l'aggravant a été acceptée par l vous
vanter les qualités de votre nouveau
ministre j'indique simplement lorsque en
deux jours il a été capable d'une part
de vanter la qualité des de la fermeture
des réseaux sociaux chinois pour éviter
la contamination du coronavirus
lorsqu'il a été capable de proposer que
la constitution supprime les termes de
sécurité sociale je crains qu'ils ne
doivent plus au fait qu'il fallait
nommer quelqu'un capable de remplacer au
pied levé en quelques heures une
ministre plutôt qu'à sa seule compétence
dont nous jugerons dans les jours à
venir
merci
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue daniel
chassa pour le groupe les indépendants
vous avez la parole monsieur le monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues ma question ça s'adresse
au ministre de la santé à qui je
souhaite la bienvenue au sénat l'article
34 du projet de loi
azap prévoit de libéraliser la vente en
ligne de médicaments l'objectif est
d'encourager le développement de
plateformes mutualisées des locaux de
stockage afin d'externaliser une partie
des activités de vendre des officines
les médicaments ne sont pas des biens de
consommation comme les autres et 95 % de
la profession mais aussi des français
sont opposés à une telle ouverture du
marché
le pharmacien est un professionnel de
santé qualifiés disponibles à l'accès
sans rendez vous il est une porte
d'entrée des soins primaires et dans la
prise en charge des soins non programmés
les missions des officines se
diversifient s'ouvrant la prévention
vaccination dépistage et aux
interventions dans les ehpad nous savons
que l'adoption de cet article va se
traduire par une perte du chiffre
d'affaires et fragiliser le modèle
économique des pharmacies pourraient
conduire à des fermetures notamment en
rural en allemagne en angleterre un
tiers des pharmacies sont menacés
monsieur le ministre la pharmacie est un
maillon incontournable dans le circuit
des médicaments pour leur prise en
charge
sécuriser ce projet remettrait en cause
de maillage territorial avec une
diminution du nombre de pharmaciens
adjoints estimée à 5000 avant la logique
commerciale nous devons préserver le
lien de proximité
cette réforme n'apparaît t'elle pas
contradictoire avec la volonté du
gouvernement d'améliorer l'offre de
soins dans les territoires notamment
ruraux
merci pour vous répondre la parole aux
communistes et solidarité à santé
monsieur olivier ferrand je lui souhaite
la bienvenue vous verrez le sénat on s'y
habitue très vite
et donc vous avez la parole merci merci
monsieur le président je suis très
honoré d'être aujourd'hui au sénat
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs cher
sénateur chassaing je voudrais dire
docteur chassaing et votre question ne
m'étonne pas car je vous sais médecin
généraliste en corrèze un département
qui parmi de nombreux départements
souffrent déjà de la désertification
médicale et c'est à ce titre que je
comprends que vous inquiéter de la
possible disparition demain des
pharmacies qui sont des maliens des
maillons essentiels de l'accès aux soins
dans ces territoires sous dotées votre
question porte sur l'article 34 du
projet de loi d'accélération et de
simplification de l'action publique qui
vise à simplifier sans remettre en cause
les équilibres de la vente en ligne
certains dispositifs de la vente en
ligne je rappelle que la vente en ligne
de médicaments est autorisé dans notre
pays depuis quelques années suite à une
décision européenne et que les
conditions d'application de cette loi en
ont énormément limiter la portée
parce que la france s'oppose à ce qu'il
y ait des grandes plateformes notamment
des plateformes étrangères qui puisse
demain vendre des médicaments aux
français dans des conditions de sécurité
et de qualité qui ne serait pas établie
et qui viendrait mettre en difficulté un
maillage territorial en pharmacie qui je
le disais est absolument essentiel
j'entends d'ailleurs que dans ce projet
le mot plateforme puisse inquiéter voire
parfois choqué le gouvernement n'a
jamais eu jamais eu l'intention d'aller
vers des plateformes de vente en ligne
de médicaments de type amazon ou autres
pour ne pas la citer et le texte prévoit
bien que cette activité doit rester sous
la seule responsabilité du pharmacien
d'officine
pour couper court à tout risque et
j'espère que cela apportera une réponse
positive dans vos inquiétudes
des amendements seront déposés pour
clarifier les dispositions applicables
et supprimer jusqu'à la notion même de
plateformes ces mesures de
simplification je le précise ne doivent
pas fragiliser des officines dont la
présence est indispensable sur le
territoire je m'y engage
en cohérence d'ailleurs avec la
politique de santé menée depuis trois
ans maintenant de notre pays par agnès
buzyn et qui vise au contraire à donner
de nouvelles missions aux pharmaciens
d'officine sur notre territoire
monsieur chat
donc merci monsieur le ministre pas de
numérisation en dehors de la pharmacie
de monsieur le ministre
d'ailleurs vous n'avez pas changé
puisque en 2014 vous déclariez que le
site internet devrait être adossée à une
pharmacie physique les patients pourront
si nécessaire se rendre à une officine
et ainsi échangez avec le pharmacien
ceci constitue une garantie majeur de
sécurité et vira évitera la
surconsommation de médicaments
eh bien j'espère que le comédien vous
suivra dans ce sens merci la parole est
maintenant aux présidents philippe bas
pour le groupe l'est républicain
vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président ma question
et pour monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le premier ministre le nouveau
président du conseil français du culte
musulman monsieur messaoui a rappelé
hier que la majorité des musulmans de
france veulent vivre leur spiritualité
dans le strict respect des valeurs de la
république
il ajoute que la volonté de faire
reculer toutes les formes de
communautarisme et en accord avec les
idéaux de fraternité des musulmans son
prédécesseur monsieur boubakeur l'avait
dit la loi de l'état et notre loup de
son côté le président de la république a
réaffirmé hier qu'on ne doit jamais
accepté que les lois de la religion
puisse être supérieure aux lois de la
république avec le président retailleau
et le président marseille dans la
continuité de ce consensus républicain
nous proposons d'écrire dans notre
constitution que nul individu ou nuls
groupe ne peut se prévaloir de ses
origines ou de ses croyances pour
s'exonérer du respect de la règle
commune
pouvons-nous déduire de la déclaration
du président de la république que votre
gouvernement soutiendra notre
proposition
pour vous répondre la parole est et au
ministre de l'intérieur monsieur pouces
comme questionnaire merci monsieur le
président mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le président philippe
bas vous l'avez dit il y a une volonté
déterminée de tous les acteurs à
commencer par les musulmans de buter
contre le séparatisme
à commencer par les musulmans parce que
ce combat nous devons le mener pour les
musulmans et avec les musulmans
et c'est la raison pour laquelle elle sa
notice delattre évoqué tout à l'heure
l'importance du mot séparatisme qui
effectivement permet d'éviter de
condamner au fond des communautés qui se
revendique comme travail en communauté
et bien au-delà de la question
religieuse et qui permet justement de
bien identifier celles et ceux qui
veulent dépasser la république outre
passé la république et ses valeurs et
contre lesquels nous devons être
mobilisés et c'est ce que nous faisons
sans attendre un texte de loi vous le
savez monsieur le président à travers
notamment ses 15 quartiers qui ont été
identifiés dès février 2018 et au sein
desquels nous avons demandé au préfet
d'être hyper mobilisés avec l'ensemble
des acteurs et des institutions
publiques pour faire reculer cette
organisation cet écosystème du
séparatisme que nous connaissons c'est
ainsi que nous aurons fermé en moins de
deux ans 15 lieux de culte 12
établissements culturels et associatifs
quatre écoles 150 débits de boissons que
nous avons mobilisé tous les moyens pour
faire des contrôles et contrôler et
redresser près de 19 millions d'euros
dans ses 15 quartiers là dès le mois de
novembre j'ai demandé à l'ensemble des
préfets que ce dispositif soit appliqué
à l'ensemble du territoire national
parce qu'il a montré son efficacité nous
devons bien évidemment agir
et puis ensuite il ya la réflexion à
laquelle vous nous invitez à laquelle le
gouvernement invitera aussi les
parlementaires
la réflexion de la traduction
législative pour aller plus loin encore
vous avez fait des propositions le
président retailleau en a fait aussi pas
d'autre mais aussi complémentaires le
débat est posé le gouvernement reviendra
aussi devant le parlement avec une
volonté de trouver les meilleurs outils
pour lutter partout contre le
séparatisme vous en effet une
travaillons ensemble avec toute la
difficulté que nous connaissons pour des
modifications constitutionnelles
mais dans tous les cas la volonté du
gouvernement est de ne pas attendre de
traduction législative et d'utiliser
tous les outils qui sont les nôtres
aujourd'hui pour être him
diatement efficace comme nous l'avons
été dans ses 15 quartiers et que nous
devons l'être de toute façon c'est un
impératif républicain sur l'ensemble du
territoire national
merci monsieur le président bas monsieur
le ministre vous avez ce rigoureusement
évité de répondre à la question je vous
ai posé n'était pas compliqué elle était
formulée directement
il faut donner un coup d'arrêt aux
communautarismes la liberté religieuse
n'autorise personne à exiger un
traitement à part dans les hôpitaux les
écoles les cantines les services publics
les transports les ateliers les bureaux
les mairies les piscines les centres
sportifs et nulle part ailleurs
la constitution est muette sur ce point
il faut donc assumer de la compléter par
une référence claire et connue de tous
nous souhaitons le faire non pas contre
le gouvernement
mais si possible avec lui le sénat en
délibérera fin mars
votre majorité devra ensuite prendre ses
responsabilités pour permettre aux
français de se prononcer par référendum
après un vote que j'espère positif du
parlement
c'est ce que la constitution prévoit et
celle attente profonde de nos
concitoyens
[Applaudissements]
la parole est maintenant à madame la
présidente valérie létard pour le groupe
de l'union centriste j'avais leur parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'économie et des finances
ainsi qu'à madame la secrétaire d'état
mme agnès pannier une hache et madame la
ministre
un an après l'échec de sa fusion avec
l'allemand siemens alstom vient
d'annoncer son souhait de racheter
bombardier transport filiale ferroviaire
du groupe canadien
cette opération s'inscrit dans un
contexte international de vive
concurrence en particulier avec le géant
chinois crc qui ne cesse de grignoter
des parts de marché en europe
le rachat de bombardier transport par
alstom s'avère donc essentiel pour
l'avenir de notre filière ferroviaire
encore faut-il que la commission
européenne ne s'oppose pas à cette
nouvelle initiative
l'état français doit bien sûr soutenir
sa filière ferroviaire au moment où la
mobilité durable est devenu un enjeu
majeur dans nos modes de déplacement
c'est pourquoi madame la ministre nous
serions heureux de connaître votre
position sur ce projet de rachat et la
stratégie de l'état pour accompagner
cette opération est à ce sujet
que pouvez vous nous dire des récents
échanges du ministre bruno le maire avec
la commissaire européenne madame v
styger en outre madame la ministre
comme dans ma région des hauts de france
des inquiétudes peuvent également surgir
chez les salariés de ces deux fleurons
industriels qui au final font le même
métier et qui pourraient craindre des
compressions de postes ou des économies
d'échelle marqué malgré un carnet de
commandes bien rempli pour ma part j'ai
la conviction qu'ils sont le plus
souvent complémentaires comme ils le
sont dans les sites de production du
valenciennois re ou bombardier à 2000
salariés et alstom 1600 mhz et madame la
ministre afin d'éclairer et de rassurer
tous les salariés comptez-vous demandé à
alstom de communiquer rapidement sur son
projet industriel sur sa stratégie en
matière d'emploi et surtout de donner
des perspectives
surtout nos sites de production en
france je vous remercie pour vos
réponses
la parole est à madame agnès pannier rue
nash et secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre de l'économie et des finances
il avait la parole madame la ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice létard vous l'avez dit alstom
c'est d'abord un groupe solide qui a un
carnet de commandes bien rempli et qui a
montré sa compétitivité sur des appels
d'offres en france et à l'international
encore ces derniers mois mais dans ce
paysage l' annonce faite par ce groupe
du rachat de bombardier est une bonne
nouvelle
une bonne nouvelle pour le groupe alstom
une bonne nouvelle pour l'industrie
européenne
pourquoi d'abord parce que au travers de
ce rachat le stum va pouvoir renforcer
son offre produit ses capacités de
recherche et développement et ses
capacités industrielles et comme vous le
dites très bien elles sont
complémentaires
deuxièmement parce que ça permet de
faire rentrer à un actionnaire cdpq la
caisse des dépôt et de placement du
québec est un actionnaire stable et
fiable
troisièmement pour l'industrie
européenne car c'est une réponse avec
cette consolidation possible à l'entrée
sur le marché de serre rrc qui
représente 30 milliards d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires le groupe composé de
bombardier alstom représenterait 15
milliards d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
alors deux questions sont posées et nous
rejoignons complètement votre analyse la
première sur le volet organisationnel
monsieur poupart-lafarge le p dg
d'alstom a dit très clairement que ce
projet était un projet de croissance
qu'il reposait sur la complémentarité
entre les sites et notamment en france
de bombardier et d'alstom et qu'il
n'était pas question de le fondée sur la
recherche de synergies terme pudique
pour parler de restructuration
donc je veux vous rassurer sur cet angle
là une des premières déclarations et
vous imaginez bien qu'avec bruno le
maire nous allons suivre cela de très
près le deuxième aspect c'est le sujet
de la concurrence avec la commission
européenne
bruno le maire a vu madame tachnag
heures hier ce point effectivement été
abordés parmi d'autres nous pensons
avoir des arguments forts pour je
portais ce dossier d'abord parce que
c'est une bonne nouvelle pour le
consommateur puisque il aura des offres
compétitives sérère
c est un groupe compétitif est également
un groupe européen et que c'est aussi
une façon d'améliorer les prix et
d'améliorer le produit et ce sous cet
angle là que nous allons porter le n'est
pas je vous remercie
la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue frédéric marchand pour le
groupe de la république en marche
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues la
pédagogie étant l'art de la répartie
répétition vous me permettrai la main
secrétaires d'état de revenir sur le
dossier alstom puisque effectivement
cela a été dit par ma collègue valérie
létard l'accord trouvé entre alstom et
la division transport de bombardier pour
le rachat de ce dernier doit permettre
au groupe français de confirmer sa
position numéro deux mondial de la
construction ferroviaire et c'est bien
évidemment une excellente nouvelle
cette annonce prend bien évidemment une
dimension toute particulière dans le
département du nord et plus spécialement
sur les deux sites voisins de
l'arrondissement de valenciennes
celui d'alstom avec ses 1300 55 salariés
à petite forêt et celui de bombardier à
crespin avec ses 2000 salariés
tous deux ont des carnets de commandes
remplis pour les 4 à 5 prochaines années
mais cette annonce positive mais
diablement la question de l'avenir qui
sera réservé aux deux sites à ce jour
alstom et bombardier travaille en
consortium sur trois projets dont le rer
angie ou le m7 le train régional belge
la complémentarité géographique des deux
groupes ainsi que celle de leurs
produits sont des atouts mis en avant
par le pdg d'alstom pour je cite
renforcer notre présence internationale
ainsi que notre capacité à répondre à la
demande toujours plus importante de
solutions de mobilité durable alstom et
bombardier c'est aussi la participation
à des projets innovants portés par le
pôle de compétitivité de portée mondiale
i trans à lille et valenciennes qui
contribuent à forger une identité
exceptionnel de ce bassin d'emploi en
matière de transport les organisations
syndicales ont fait part de plusieurs
réactions à cette annonce et de crainte
qu'ils sont à tout à fait légitimes
notamment s'agissant des postes en
doublons mais aussi de la pérennité du
site bombardier de crespin
madame la secrétaire d'état je vous sais
tout comme monsieur le ministre de
l'économie et des finances
particulièrement attachée au
développement de notre stratégie
industrielle et de la dynamique de
l'emploi aussi quels éléments pouvez
vous nous apportez permettant de
garantir au sein
arie que ce nouveau champion ferroviaire
sera aussi le champion de l'emploi dans
un département du nord qui a payé un
lourd tribut à toutes les
restructurations industrielles pour vous
répondre la parole et hop
madame agnès pannier runel chez madame
la ministre la parole merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs
monsieur le député marc jean alors
pardon
monsieur le sénateur faut que ça arrive
une fois à chacun monsieur le sénateur
marchand a les yeux je veux redire ici
projets que vous avez bien résumé
l'enjeu de ce projet c'est finalement de
faire un acteur plus fort sur le marché
du ferroviaire dans un moment où le
ferroviaire est en croissance et une des
réponses à la question de la transition
écologique dans les transports et donc
c'est plutôt une assurance pour les
salariés de ce groupe alstom plus
bombardier que d'avoir plus de force
plus de force en matière de recherche et
développement plus de force en tint en
matière de portefeuille produits plus
sur une plus grande capacité à répondre
à des appels d'offres non seulement en
europe mais au plan international et
plus de force dans les capacités
industrielles puisque cela va aussi
alimenter une excellence industrielle et
de partage de bonnes pratiques entre les
deux groupes
et je crois que le président directeur
général d'alstom ne l'a pas caché son
projet est un projet de croissance c'est
un projet de conquête
c'est un projet de conquête par rapport
notamment à un acteur chinois qui
essaient rrc qui est en train de vous
l'avez très bien dit madame la
présidente de grignoter des parts de
marché mondial et nous devons nous nous
armer avec un groupe suffisamment fort
pour être capable de répondre de manière
forte à 7 à cette compétition
il faut aussi vis-à-vis de la commission
européenne faire valoir les conditions
d'une concurrence loyale il semblerait
que ces rrc soit un peu porté par le
gouvernement et l'environné qu'au
système chinois
c'est un point que nous souhaitons aussi
adressé vis-à-vis de la commission
européenne je vous remercie
le couteau
merci la parole est à notre collègue
patrick chaize pour le groupe l'est
républicain avait la parole monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues hans hess
a récemment publié un rapport
préliminaire sur l'impact sanitaire de
la 5g s'appuyant sur des études
scientifiques déjà disponibles lagence
conclu pour l'heure à un manque
important voire à une absence de données
scientifiques sur les effets biologiques
et sanitaires potentiels de la 5g il
ressort en effet que deux inconnus
principales doivent être levés
la première découle de l'absence
d'études spécifiques aux bandes de
fréquences qui seront utilisés notamment
le 26 gertz la deuxième tient une des
spécificités de la 5g le ciblage du
signal sur les utilisateurs qui implique
un temps d'exposition cours des
personnes mais à des niveaux
d'exposition élevée des réponses à ces
deux questions pourraient être apportées
par le rapport final de l'ansès prévu
pour le premier trimestre 2001 21
or la procédure d'attribution des
fréquences aux opérateurs se déroulera
très prochainement et les premiers
déploiements devraient avoir lieu cet
été
il est pourtant évident que le bond
technologique que constitue la 5g ne
sera accepté qu'au prix d'une
rationalisation du débat public
ce que ne permet pas le calendrier
actuel madame la ministre pourrait vous
réellement tenir compte des conclusions
du rapport de l'osce s à collecte alors
que les fréquences ont déjà été
attribuées aux opérateurs et que la 5g
aura commencé à être déployés je
rappelle enfin que les efforts de
rationalisation ne doivent pas seulement
porter sur le volet sanitaire mais aussi
sur son aspect environnemental
le président de l'ademe auditionné dans
le cadre de la mission d'information
relative à l'empreinte environnementale
du numérique que j'ai l'honneur de
présider ainsi déploré qu'aucune étude
d'impact environnemental sur le
déploiement doit cinq gènes étaient est
menée madame la ministre
allez vous enfin à mener une évaluation
de l'impact environnemental de la 5g
je vous remercie
madame la ministre madame pas dire c'est
merci monsieur le monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur chaise merci pour
votre question monsieur le sénateur car
elle me permet peut-être d'apporter un
certain nombre d'éléments au débat
important que vous posez sur la l'impact
sur la santé et sur l'environnement du
déploiement de la 5g
la première chose que je veux dire sur
ce débat c'est qu'il ya aujourd'hui une
réglementation qui vise à limiter les
émissions sur les individus de toutes
formes de technologies
s'agissant des ondes électromagnétiques
donc cette réglementation elle
s'appliquer aussi bien la 2g à la 3g
qu'à la 4g est donc à la 5g actuellement
donc nous sommes dans un environnement
qui est d'ores et déjà régulés et
réguler sur la base de recommandations
soutenu par le m s est posée par un
groupe d'experts qui luxener deuxième
élément aujourd'hui la nfl dans toutes
les expérimentations de la 5g fait des
mesures et ces mesures sont partagés au
travers d'un comité qui réunit les
associations de consommateurs les élus
locaux et les opérateurs et qui vise
justement à accompagner ces
expérimentations et en tirer un certain
nombre de d'éléments de d'enseignement
pour le déploiement de la 5g donc ce
sujet effet en transparence et
accompagner c'est d'ailleurs un élément
assez fondamental de la feuille de
déploiement de la 5g qui a été mise en
place en juillet 2018
troisième élément vous avez raison de
souligner que sur la bande 26 gigahertz
sur lequel nous faisons les tests il y a
peu de recul en revanche sur la bande
sur lequel nous allons donner les
fréquences qui concerne donc l'appel
d'offres nous avons dû recul puisque ce
sont des ondes dans lequel nous baignons
pour d'autres usages depuis des années
je veux le rappeler parce que je pense
que c'est important
dernier point sur la 5g n'oubliez pas
que plus on est loin d'une antenne et
plus il est difficile d'avoir un accès
plus vous avez des missions donc ça
fonctionne
bahar au but de ce que l'on croît
naturellement ce n'est pas l'antenne qui
fait peur c'est au contraire la
difficulté à se connecter je vous
remercier monsieur chaize
oui j'appelle dans maints ministre vous
l'avez dit effectivement il faut des
experts lançait ce sont des experts et
lens s ne nous donne pas confiance en
l'occurrence pour pouvoir développer un
réseau comme celui là il faut de la
confiance et on sait très bien notamment
pour l'acceptation des antennes dans nos
territoires
une inconnue multiples existe soit 5 g
il faudrait évidemment le débat avec
huawei donc il est utile d'avoir
rapidement une vision et un projet
construit merci la parole est à notre
collègue yves daudigny pour le groupe
socialiste et républicain
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre des
solidarités et de la santé
mes félicitations républicaines monsieur
le ministre pour votre nomination
parmi les dossiers abandonné sur votre
bureau par votre prédécesseur
ma question porte sur les pénuries de
médicaments elles se multiplient en
france titrait récemment un hebdomadaire
un pharmacien résume ainsi la situation
je cite les problèmes se multiplient
on ne sait même pas comment répondre aux
patients qui veulent savoir pourquoi
leurs médicaments n'est pas disponible
et on ne s'avance plus sur des dates de
retour à la normale à l'hôpital
la disponibilité de certaines classes
thérapeutiques conduit à des pertes de
chance inacceptable pour les patients en
raison du corona virus les inquiétudes
portent sur l'approvisionnement de
matières premières excipients ou
principe actif massivement apporté
depuis l'asie une question 4 points
monsieur le ministre
pouvez-vous nous rassurer sur les
résultats de l'analyse demande l agence
nationale de sécurité du médicament afin
d'identifier les risques possibles de
ruptures liées au corona virus où en
sommes nous de la mise en oeuvre des
dispositions votées fans 2019 c'est vrai
ya pas très longtemps en particulier de
l'obligation pour les industriels de
constituer des stocks de sécurité de
deux à quatre mois
une expertise est elle menée pour la
mise en place d'un programme public de
production de quelques médicaments
exposés à des tensions
d'approvisionnement et enfin
envisagez-vous de nouvelles initiatives
dans le cadre européen pour remédier à
une situation qui inquiète fortement nos
concitoyens je vous remercie pour vous
répondre la parole et quand monsieur
olivier verront maëlys des solidarités
de notre santé vous avez la parole
messieurs mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur yves daudigny
shérif de dénis on se connaît
effectivement on a eu le plaisir de
travailler suffisamment ensemble je ne
suis pas étonné à la fois de la question
que vous posez qui est une question tout
à fait légitime et d'ailleurs vous avez
posé vous même les jalons de la réponse
dans les questions que vous avez posé en
quatre points et je voudrais y revenir
vous avez d'abord cité les mesures
prises par le gouvernement dans le cadre
du dernier budget de la sécurité sociale
de façon à lutter contre les ruptures de
stock
j'en rappelle les mesures essentielles
un stock qui devra être portée à quatre
mois d'ailleurs qui a été amendé par
voie parlementaire par les députés et
par les sénateurs pour faire en sorte
que ces stocks ne soient pas en chine
sur les sites de production ça n'aurait
pas eu de sens mais directement sur le
sol européen
il ya également un engagement pris par
les laboratoires auxquels ils sont
désormais contraints de faire venir à
leurs frais des médicaments en
remplacement de ceux de ceux qui
seraient en pénurie en cas de
médicaments d'intérêt thérapeutique
majeur vous avez ensuite abordé la
question l'industrialisation
je crois que c'est la clé je crois que
nous pouvons mettre en place toutes les
mesures que nous voulons pour lutter
contre les ruptures de stock
il faut que nous ayons à nouveau de
l'autonomie dans la production
européenne n'ont pas française mais
européenne de médicaments
je crois qu'il est là à la fois un enjeu
sanitaire un enjeu pour la
réindustrialisation du pays
j'attends que me soient remis le rapport
qui avait été confié par ma
prédécesseure agnès buzyn à monsieur
biot et qui portera notamment sur cette
question de l'enjeu de la
réindustrialisation on peut pas être
dépendant à 90% pour les médicaments de
pays comme la chine l'inde le pakistan
il faut que nous ayons retrouvé la
souveraineté européenne en la matière
vous poser une question en particulier
sur le coronavirus sachez que la rsm
j'attends et je suis au quotidiennement
en contact avec eux j'attends tous les
signaux d'alerté potentiel pour
certaines ruptures de stock vous l'avez
dit
la chine fait face à une épidémie qui
met en jeu parfois les sites de
production pour l'instant il n'y a aucun
signal d' alerte qu'ils soient passés au
rouge
mais ce n'est pas une démarche nationale
monsieur le sénateur c'est une démarche
à nouveau européenne et même mondiale
et pour conclure vous informer que sur
ce sujet notamment
je serai demain en contact avec tous mes
homologues ministre de la santé du g7
dans le cas du g7 santé sur le génie oui
merci monsieur le ministre de la réponse
mais si vous le permettez encore une
observation
le prix de certains médicaments anciens
est devenu aujourd'hui trop bas pour
justifier encore leur fabrication
mais dans le même temps je prends
l'exemple du pic sans 2,1 milliards de
chiffre d'affaires en 2010 9 10
milliards visés pour 2025 36 milliards
de chiffre d'affaires un résultat net de
2 8 milliards pour le laboratoire la
réflexion n'est pas épuisé sur ce sujet
je vous remercie
merci la parole est à notre collègue
florence lassarade pour le groupe l'est
républicain
j'avais la parole merci monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
mes chers collègues ma question porte
sur le départ précipité du gouvernement
de la ministre de la santé madame lizin
a démissionné de son poste pour
reprendre pied levé la campagne de
benjamin griveaux dans les circonstances
que l'on sait cette démission intervient
au moment où la crise du court aux
navires us fait son premier mort en
france où la réforme des retraites est
quasiment dans l'impasse et où l'hôpital
public traverse une crise profonde et
durable
je regrette en particulier que les
mesures prises pour le personnel
soignant concerne essentiellement les
hôpitaux parisiens
il ya de l'incompréhension et de
l'étonnement
car être ministre du nouveau monde
n'empêche visiblement pas de faire
campagne pour les élections municipales
vous même monsieur le premier ministre
vous faites campagne war monsieur
darmana ministre d'action et des comptes
publics à tourcoing monsieur franck
risser ministre de la culture à
coulommiers
madame marianne chapa secrétaire d'état
chargée de l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes et de la lutte contre les
discriminations
dans le 14e arrondissement monsieur
lecornu ministre chargé des
collectivités territoriales à vernon
madame darrieussecq secrétaire d'état
auprès de la ministre des armées à
mont-de-marsan et monsieur marc fesneau
ministre chargé des relations avec le
parlement à marche noire
doit-on comprendre que dans le nouveau
monde
on peut être ministre à temps partiel et
se présente à une élection tout en
annonçant à l'avancé que l'on ne siègera
pas comme maire dans ce contexte la
démission de la ministre la santé
s'apparente encore plus à une désertion
alors pour quelle région madame busan
at-elle été obligé de démissionner du
gouvernement pour faire campagne à paris
vont vous répondre
monsieur verrons
maëlys des solidarités de la santé
madame la sénatrice florence lassarade
au nom de la majorité à laquelle
j'appartiens
merci merci d'avoir cité les nombreuses
villes dans lesquelles nous avons des
candidats d' extrêmement grande qualité
et qui portera nos couleurs à l'occasion
des élections municipales
bah si si c'est moi qui l'avais fait ça
aurait pu m'être reprochée mais ça vient
de vous donc je vous en remercie
sincèrement je vous en remercie je vous
remercie également à l'âme la sénatrice
pour l'émotion que vous véhiculez à
l'idée que le grand ministre de la santé
comme agnès buzyn ait pu quitter son
ministère puisque à travers le regret
que vous exprimez qu'elle soit partie
j'imagine que vous étiez extrêmement
favorable à la politique et la conduite
et puisqu'il me revient de vous répondre
je vais en profiter à mon tour pour
assurer la promotion de son action parce
que je crois qu'elle le mérite
l'action de madame buzyn c'est le reste
à charge héros le reste à charge et
rocky été mis en place en seulement deux
ans dans notre pays à l'heure à laquelle
je vous parle
soixante dix mille français 70 des
français ont déjà un équipement
d'audioprothèse sang reste à charge plus
de 2,5 millions de soins dentaires ont
été réalisés sans aucun reste à charge
un plan pauvreté est en train d'être
déclinée sur tout le territoire avec le
soutien incommensurable et des
secrétaires d'état christelle du boss et
adrien taquet qui permet notamment aux
enfants de pouvoir se nourrir
correctement à l'école d'avoir accès à
la cantine à bas prix d'avoir des petits
déjeuners gratuits à l'école l'action
madame busin en matière de politique
sociale n'est absolument pas absolument
pas à reprendre tellement elle était
ambitieuse pour notre pays c'est aussi
l'action pour les 1000 premiers jours
pour la famille qui est porté par adrien
taquet et fait un plan d'investissement
sans pareil pour l'hôpital public 150
millions d'euros d'investissement qui
sont en ce moment distribués dans les
différents hôpitaux
la reprise de 10 milliards d'euros de la
dette hospitalière dont tout le monde
aurait rêvé sur tous les bords de cette
assemblée de cette assemblée
sénatoriales et encore et encore donc
soyez rassurés en tant que ministre de
la santé et des solidarités je suis prêt
à assurer la relève à poursuivre
l'action remarquable qu'elle a débuté
dans le pays est encore une fois merci
adam la charade quelques secondes
monsieur le ministre vous avez vite
appris vous n'avez pas répondu à ma
question
la parole et par notre collègue
élisabeth doineau pour le groupe de
l'union centriste
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames messieurs les
ministres
ma question s'adresse à adria taquet
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
la santé et des solidarités
le 30 janvier dernier l'assemblée
nationale examinait la proposition de
loi de notre collègue député udi agir
libri coûts visant à allonger le congé
de deuil après le décès d'un enfant
le texte adopté était nettement en
retrait des ambitions initiales de
l'auteur et il a suscité du coup une
émission bien légitime par des parents
concernés une émotion aussi de la part
des partenaires sociaux de l'opinion
générale en public en général et du
gouvernement pour finir en tant que
rapporteur de ce texte est en accord
avec les ministres que j'ai pu
rencontrer depuis muriel pénicaud et
justement adrien taquet je souhaite que
nous puissions travailler ensemble et
aller plus loin dans l'accompagnement
des familles endeuillées
techniquement pour éviter les fourches
caudines de l'article 40 de la
constitution le gouvernement doit
s'engager sur un certain nombre de
points
êtes vous prêt à prévoir une prise en
charge par la solidarité nationale de
tout ou partie de ce congé qui
aujourd'hui serait de 15 jours détendre
à 25 ans la limite d'âge à garantir le
même droit pour les indépendants et les
fonctionnaires êtes vous prêt à mettre
en place une aide financière universel
pour les obsèques
et de quel montant êtes vous favorable
au maintien des prestations familiales
trois mois après le décès d enfants ces
points sont extrêmement importants est
particulièrement attendu par les
familles et par les associations de
soutien
bien sûr au delà de ces aspects
financiers nous le savons les uns et les
autres
l'accompagnement social administratif et
médico psychologique est tout aussi
important pour les familles touchées par
un tel drame
pour vous répondre la parole est à notre
homme un dry attaqué secrétaire d'état
auprès de lui des solidarités de la
santé monsieur ministre avait la parole
a encore votre collègue monsieur le
président merci
dams et messieurs les sénateurs madame
la sénatrice de nos questions du congé
deuil permettez moi de parler de
peut-être de répit de deuil plutôt que
de cangé deuil a effectivement fait
l'objet d'un certain nombre de débats et
de concertation ces dernières semaines
concertation que nous avons mené avec
avec muriel pénicaud avec des
parlementaires dont guy bricout que vous
avez que vous avez cités concertation
auprès à la fois des associations qui
accompagnent ces familles depuis de
nombreuses années mais aussi des
partenaires sociaux alors que nous
disent que nous disent les familles que
oui la question de la durée de ce répit
de deuil est un sujet important qu'il
faut probablement qu'il faut l'allonger
à 12 soit à 15 jours et madame la
sénatrice l'état à cet égard prendra ses
responsabilités mais elles nous disent
que la question du délai n'est pas la
seule question qu'il s'agit bien de
mettre en place de bâtir ensemble un
véritable accompagnement de ces familles
un accompagnement financier avec la mise
en place d'une prestation universelle
pour permettre à ces familles notamment
de faire face aux frais d'obsèques la
question vous avez cité de la
prolongation certain nombre
d'allocations qui ne doivent plus
s'arrêter du jour au lendemain mais est
encore un accompagnement psychologique à
la fois pour les parents mais également
pour les frères et les soeurs nous avons
l'occasion madame la sénatrice avec vous
avec cette assemblée la nation tout
entière de bâtir un véritable
accompagnement global pour ces familles
et qui peut faire véritablement office
de modèle en europe
mais vous savez madame la sénatrice
cette question nous renvoie une question
bien plus large encore qu'est la
question de l'accompagnement des
familles françaises
quand la grossesse l'accouchement se
passe mal je reviens je termine 6 mois
de rencontres avec les familles de
france aux quatre coins du territoire et
le moc et le qui est le plus revenus
dans ces rencontres c'est celui de
solitude les femmes se sentent seules
elles se sentent seuls pendant la
grossesse quand la grossesse se passe
mal notamment quand il ya un risque de
prématurité
elles se sentent seuls face à une fausse
couche
se sentent seuls face aux risques postes
partout mais elles se sentent seuls en
cas elles se sentent seuls quand leur
mari va retourner le falher klur au bout
de onze jours madame la sénatrice nous
avons l'occasion de briser un certain
nombre de tabous et de bâtir une
véritable politique d'accompagnement
pour les familles de france c'est tout
l'objet du projet des mille jours qui
donnera l'occasion à des annonces d'ici
l'été je vous remercie
la parole est à notre collègue jean marc
boyer pour le groupe l'est républicain
chez le président ma question s'adresse
à madame la ministre à cohésion des
territoires
madame la ministre un rapport de
l'assemblée nationale sur les zones de
revitalisation rurale zrr préconise de
recentraliser le soutien à leur ruralité
un rapport récent du sénat ou
préconisent de tenir compte de la
réalité de renouveler ce dispositif de
soutien aux territoires ruraux les
ederer sont vécues comme un dispositif
de justice tout en respectant la libre
administration territoriale l'utilité du
dispositif ne fait aucun doute
notamment en offrant une fiscalité
adaptée aux acteurs économiques qui font
le choix de la ruralité des sept
générations fiscale en sont la preuve
sont porteuses de le lier d'attractivité
et soutiennent nos tissus de proximité
or votre politique au service des
métropoles abandonne la proximité
pourtant essentiel en ruralité aussi la
re centralisation étatique war étatiste
de vos décisions et mal vécues par nos
concitoyens dans nos villages qui y
voient un pouvoir central qui gère d'en
haut sans comprendre et tenir compte de
leurs besoins
nos citoyens ruraux attendent désormais
de vraies mesures et pas seulement de la
com ils craignent cette recentralisation
avec la réforme que vous envisagez des
ederer madame la ministre
comptez-vous mettre fin aux ederer et
transféré le dispositif et des moyens
dans l'adn terre et ainsi mettre fin un
support économique essentiel pour vous
répondre
la parole est à madame la ministre de la
cohésion des territoires une violation
et que les collectivités terrible
le même bourreau monsieur le sénateur
merci pour votre question sur les zrr
vous rappeler que les et des rêves ont
été je vous vois pas voilà merci
monsieur ont été décidées en 1995 et
qu'une loi récente en 2015 applicable en
2010 est à modifier l'application des
ederer aujourd'hui il y a à peu près la
moitié des communes françaises monsieur
le sénateur qui sont en zrr
or en juin de cette année environ 4000
commune devait sortir du système
le premier ministre a annoncé que le
qu'il y aurait report de cette décision
jusqu'à la fin de l'année 2020 alors
pourquoi vous avez cité un rapport de
l'assemblée nationale mais il y a eu
aussi un rapport au sénat monsieur le
sénateur de vos collègues messieurs
delcros et pointereau et de madame
espagnac et qu'il n'était justement il
nous avons travaillé ensemble et dans
une comment dire un travail de
coopération décentralisée si je puis me
permettre
et nous avons décidé ensemble qu'il
était utile de revoir une géographie
prioritaire de la ruralité comme l'a
annoncé le premier ministre lors du
congrès des maires ruraux en septembre
de l'année dernière
au fond le travail des sénateurs le
travail de l'agenda rural nous permet
d'envisager au fond peut-être une
politique plus ciblée sur les secteurs
qui en ont le plus besoin nous allons
donc travailler avec les parlementaires
avec les délégations aux collectivités
territoriales et nous avons même lancé
avec le premier ministre et avec les
inspections générales
une évaluation de la politique des zrr
et en fonction de tous ces résultats et
de toutes ces études nous prendrons une
décision ensemble et non pas
centralisées monsieur le sénateur font
confiance
d'année merci monsieur boyer madame la
ministre
nos villages de france du plus petit au
bourg centre font la richesse de notre
pays
or nos citoyens et des élus ruraux se
sentent abandonnés dans nos territoires
je regrette votre absence de vision
globale de la ruralité
vous nous parlez d'agenda rival
d'agencés nationales des territoires de
géographie prioritaire mais ce sont des
remèdes de soins palliatifs pour notre
vanité il faut sauver nos villages il
faut sauver nos campagnes pour cela ils
n'ont pas besoin de rendez vous dans un
agenda
ils ont besoin de moyens d'une vision
d'une vraie politique d'aménagement du
territoire qui n'existe plus depuis
jacques chirac
merci la parole est à notre collègue
didier rambaud pour le groupe la
république en marche
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre des sports depuis le témoignage
glaçons de la patineuse sarah abitbol
une vague de témoignages d'athlètes
abusé sexuellement dans leur jeunesse
éclater au grand jour et au delà du
patinage artistique ce sont les mondes
de l'escala du ski du tennis est
maintenant de l'équitation qui sont
concernés faisant des abus sexuels dans
le sport un scandale qui renvoie
irrémédiablement l'état à ses
responsabilités parler d'abus sexuels me
paraît à vrai dire bien pudique
quand il s'agit plutôt en réalité de
témoignages de pédocriminalité dans les
clubs sportifs qui accueille nos enfants
dans nos territoires
sachez madame la ministre que notre
appui devrait totale tant il est urgent
d'agir
j'aimerais à ce titre salué
l'organisation de la convention
nationale de prévention des violences
sexuelles dans le sport qui se tiendra
dans deux jours elle va dans le bon sens
puisque la pédocriminalité dépasse hélas
très largement le cadre du sport et que
tous les acteurs tous sans exception
doivent être mobilisés
de la même manière la piste de
l'élargissement du contrôle
d'honorabilité aux bénévoles qui
encadrent les mineurs dans le monde
sportif paraît très opportune mais le
bénévolat n'est pas la seule faille du
système
j'aimerais particulièrement attirer
votre attention sur le modèle entraîneur
élèves qui structurent largement le
monde du sport et qui crée parfois une
dépendance psychologique extrême
laquelle rendent les mineurs vulnérables
à la pédocriminalité notamment lorsque
l'entraîneur on vient presque à se
substituer à la famille aussi
pouvez-vous nous garantir madame la
ministre que le futur projet doit sport
et société se donnera les moyens de
mettre définitivement un terme à ce
crime révoltant
merci vous répondre la parole et à
madame la ministre des sports vous avez
la parole madame la ministre monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur rambo
merci pour votre question et votre
soutien le soutient d'ailleurs trans
partisan que vous avez pu me manifester
manifester publiquement sur cette
thématique
il est indispensable dans cette période
tu allais dire de transparence salutaire
que traverse le sport français
comme vous l'avez évoqué les témoignages
des victimes leur nombre leur gravité
leur persistance dans le temps et
l'impunité dans laquelle ces crimes ce
sont ces crimes se sont déroulés sont
aussi choquant que bouleversant ils le
sont pour le grand public pour le
mouvement sportif pour les tailles ses
agents je tenais à remercier les agents
de mon ministère pour leur mobilisation
en urgence sur l' écoute de la parole
qui se libèrent chaque jour vendredi
vous l'avais dit après demain avec
nicole belloubet adrien tac et marlène
schiappa nous réunissons tous les
acteurs dont les parlementaires pour une
convention nationale de prévention des
violences sexuelles dans le sport car la
pédocriminalité vous l'avez dit aussi
n'est pas un sujet spécifique aux sports
un enfant sur cinq en europe en est
victime
et le sport doit apporter sa pierre à
l'édifice d'une société plus sûre pour
nos enfants
tout le monde doit s'approprier cette
vigilance de chaque instant et le
pilotage des actions à mener main dans
la main avec les collectivités et avec
le mouvement sportif
l'objectif c'est de bâtir collectivement
un plan national de prévention robuste
et efficace
il passera en partie par la loi sport
que vous avez évoquées et sur laquelle
nous travaillons activement pour le
printemps 2020 on va y renforcer le
contrôle de l'honorabilité
des bénévoles et les obligations à
l'égard des fédérations des dirigeants
et des éducateurs
mais cette vigilance devra aussi passer
par des actions éducatives de formation
et de prévention sensibiliser les
enfants sur leur rapport à leur propre
corps chose qui n'est pas fait souvent
dans notre société même dans le cadre
familial et le sport peut y jouer un
grand rôle
former les éducateurs sur les limites à
poser et à tenir dans les relations
athlètes entraînés que vous avez évoqué
agir de manière constante pour dire
qu'il est important de parler de
dénoncer de signaler est arrivé à nos
coordonnées entre l'état les
associations spécialisées les familles
les collectivités les associations
sportives le lot fédération pour que ça
n'arrive plus dans le monde du sport est
ni dans la société merci la parole est
peut-être notre collègue jean marie
morisset pour le groupe l'est
républicain
merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre et solidarité de la
santé c'est avec une grande émotion que
mon collègue philippe pouillé moi même
vous pose cette question d'actualité à
la suite du drame qui s'est produit à
l'hôpital psychiatrique de thouars dans
le département des deux sèvres
c'était le 2 jeudi 13 février dernier
dans le cadre de son travail
elodie jeune infirmière de 31 ans mère
de deux enfants en bas âge a succombé à
un coup de couteau mortel donnée par un
patient ayant en ce moment une pensée
pour sa famille pour ses proches pour
ses collègues de travail et l'ensemble
des salariés du centre hospitalier du
nord deux sèvres que le délégué
ministériel à la santé mentale et la
psychiatrie est venu rencontrer le
lendemain du drame
beaucoup de questions se posent quant
aux conditions dans lesquelles ce drame
s'est déroulé une enquête judiciaire est
bien entendu en cours mais nous pouvons
d'ores et déjà pointé les nombreuses
insuffisances qui touchait
établissements comme partout en france
le service de psychiatrie sont engorgés
la sécurité n'est plus assurée la
qualité des soins n'est satisfaisante ni
pour les patients ni pour ceux qui les
délivre
les conditions de travail sont parfois
indignes personnel est à bout de souffle
ce drame met en lumière un seul mini ses
insuffisances en quantité de personnel
le manque de moyens matériels des
besoins en termes de formation et bien
qu'élevé au rang de priorité par votre
gouvernement dans le cadre du plan
national ma santé 2022 la psychiatrie et
la santé mentale reste le parent pauvre
du secteur de la santé alors que le
nombre de personnes prises en charges
explosent nous ne pourrons plus nous
contenter de constat de diagnostic de
conclusions de rapports il convient
maintenant d'agir urgemment et
concrètement le seul ministre à la suite
de votre prise de fonction vous avez
prévu de vous rendre dans les prochains
jours sur le site de thouars le
personnel du centre hospitalier
appréciera votre démarche mais quelles
sont les mesures d'urgence que vous
pensez leur annoncer pour éviter que ce
type de drame ne se reproduise
je vous remercie vous répondre monsieur
le ministre des solidarités et de la
chanter vous avez la parole monsieur le
sénateur jean marie morisset permettez
moi de partager l'émotion qui est réel
avec vous avec votre collègue avec
l'ensemble de la communauté médicale
quand je dis médical vie inclut
l'ensemble des soignants et des cadres
administratifs sans faire de l'histoire
personnelle il se trouve que pendant mon
internat de médecine à grenoble j'ai
travaillé pendant six mois comme interne
dans un service de psychiatrie
j'ai vu la difficulté de l'exercice au
quotidien j'ai vu la richesse du contact
avec les malades
mais avec parfois des gens qui sont dans
une situation de délire qui souffre de
pathologies psychiatriques extrêmement
lourdes pathologies psychotique parfois
de dépression extrêmement grave et qui
font que c'est un exercice de la
médecine si particulier que parfois ils
présentent des situations de dangerosité
dans les conséquences sont intolérables
et je vous rejoins parfaitement sur
cette question vous l'avez souligné le
délégué ministériel à la santé mentale
s'est rendu sur les lieux j'ai annoncé
hier que je me rendrai sur les lieux
sans presse à la rencontre des équipes
hospitalières pour discuter et faire le
point sur le traumatisme qui reste je
l'imaginent d'immenses quelques jours
après le drame qui a touché cette jeune
infirmière
famille de 31 ans vous posez la question
des moyens accordés à la santé mentale
dans notre pays il ne faut pas se mentir
la santé mentale a été trop longtemps le
parent pauvre de la médecine dans notre
pays des établissements de santé
vétustes des équipes qui manquent de
médecins vous savez il ya dix ans il
manquait déjà près de 1500 postes de
psychiatres dans les hôpitaux non pas
parce qu'il n'y a pas de budget mais
parce qu'il n'ya pas de psychiatres pour
occuper ces postes
la démographie médicale étant ce qu'elle
est notamment et c'est pourquoi il y à
des mesures très importantes ont été
prises en faveur de la santé mentale une
augmentation du budget de 80 millions
d'euros pour la seule année 2010 9 une
augmentation de 140 millions pour la
seule année 2000 vingt ans nous sommes
en train de finaliser les projets
territoriaux de santé mentale d'ici à la
fin au début de l'été 2020 des mesures
importantes ont été prises et budgété
dans le cadre du dernier budget de la
sécurité sociale je vous garantis que le
gouvernement a pris à bras le corps ce
sujet de la santé mentale et j'espère
que vous avez compris c'est aussi une
question personnelle
merci tu es morisset quelques secondes
oui merci merci monsieur le ministre l'a
fait plus de dix ans la commission des
affaires sociales s'est penché sur la
psychiatrie des rapports ont été
nombreux les auditions des ministres
également et de guti aux mêmes
conclusions vous nous en effet par la
psychiatrie est parent pauvre la réalité
est alarmante et nous comptons sur vous
monsieur le ministre pour revoir
l'organisation de la santé mon talent
sur le terrain et donner les moyens
budgétaires suffisants pour prendre en
compte
effectivement le quotidien de nos
soignants merci merci la parole est à
notre collègue monique lubin pour le
groupe socialiste
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre des solidarités de la santé
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion dans cet
hémicycle et d'interpeller le
gouvernement sur le caractère anxiogène
de la réforme des retraites donc sur
jeannette anctil comporte des
imprécisions et d'inconnu je rappelle au
passage et les termes du conseil d'état
qui parle d'insécurité juridique conseil
d'état dont finalement vous n'avez pas
grand chose à faire puisque après
l'annonce d'une conférence des
financements qui rendra ses conclusions
postérieurement au vote si du moins elle
va au bout de son travail
après les démissions ou la désertion
selon un des différents responsables du
dossier je pourrais encore citer
beaucoup de choses voilà que dans un
ciel passablement assombri nous voyons
arriver ce que j'appelle un os ni un
objet statistiques non identifié j'ai
nommé le revenu moyen par tête qui
n'existe pas et donc pourtant vous nous
expliquer que ça sera l'alpha et l'oméga
de la garantie de la dombes baisse du
point ainsi de suite
et de la façon dont nous pourrons être
heureux avec ce futur régime de retraite
chaque jour qui passe apporte son lot
d'incongruités et je rajoute à cela que
d'ici 2030 cette date des premières
liquidation de retraite nouvelle version
nous verrons pas ces quatre mandature et
au minimum deux présidents de la
république avec ce que cela veut dire
d'incertitude vous le savez quand même
monsieur le ministre comment dans ces
conditions les français pourraient-ils
vous faire confiance ils ont bien
compris que rien absolument rien dans ce
projet n'est sécurisé donc nous
considérons qu'il vous reste deux
possibilités monsieur le ministre vous
avez le choix entre une sagesse
responsable qui vous amènerait à retirer
ce dossier où une obstination qui
deviendrait coupable quelle voie choisir
et vous
[Applaudissements]
madame la sénatrice monique lubin
vous avez parlé de confiance vous avez
raison c'est là tout l'enjeu
la confiance elle est où aujourd'hui la
confiance dans le système actuel des
retraites
interrogées les français près des trois
quarts d'entre vous disent qu'avec le
système actuel des retraites
lorsqu'ils rentrent sur le marché du
travail ils considèrent que leur chance
de bénéficier d'un système de retraite
par répartition sont quasiment nulles la
confiance n'existe pas dans le système
actuel
j'ai 39 ans madame la sénatrice j'ai
effectué plusieurs métiers dans la vie
plus dure mission j'ai cotisé à quatre
régimes différents de retraite quatre
régimes différents de retraite à l'âge
de 39 ans j'ai demandé à des experts à
des statisticiens de m'expliquer ce qui
avait servi pour ma retraite
est ce que quand j'étais aide-soignante
dans une ehpad pendant une semaine est
ce que ça comptait non ça ne comptait
pas est ce que quand j'ai travaillé sur
les marchés en mairie est ce que ça
compte et ça ne comptait pas à quel âge
j'avais pourrait arrêter de travailler
lors même que j'ai commencé des jobs dès
l'âge de 18 ans on m'a répondu 67 ans
vous croyez que ma génération a
confiance dans le système actuel des
retraites ce que nous visons justement
c'est avoir une transformation pour un
régime universel dont les règles sont
claires qui fonctionne par point et non
par trimestre avec un système qui
s'appliquera pour tout le monde qu'il
soit dans le public ou dans le privé
vous inquiétez madame la sénatrice et je
peux le comprendre de la création d'un
nouvel indicateur mais encore une fois
cet indicateur n'existe que parce que la
loi lui demande existe et on ne peut pas
demander un d'indicateurs d'exister de
préexisté à la loi qui le crée et cet
indicateur il ne n'atterrit pas nulle
part si vous lisez le rapport de jean
paul delevoye
il existait déjà cet indicateur je peux
vous répondre d'ores et déjà madame sans
vous donner l'algorithme précis pour 80%
à peu près de cet indicateur
ce sera les revenus des salariés mais
comme il n'y a pas que des salariés de
notre pays
il y a également et vous le savez des
travailleurs libéraux des indépendants
du tenant compte de tous les revenus des
français pour avoir justement un
indicateur qui soit juste et vous avez
je peux vous garantir deux choses qui
ont été votées en commission des
affaires sociales en commission spéciale
à l'assemblée nationale la semaine
dernière dans le cas de la loi organique
qui elle a pu être adoptée dans l'est
dans les délais la valeur du point ne
baissera pas et quoi qu'il arrive les
pensions des retraités ne pourront pas
baissé je crois que ce sont là deux
indicateurs importants pour la confiance
des français
adam lubat quelques secondes mais non
mais monsieur monsieur le ministre yaya
plus que vous qui croyez en ce que vous
dites là comment peut-on comment peut-on
à l'échéance de 17 ans voire de 40 ans
affirmé aujourd'hui que les retraites ne
baisseront pas en plus avec un indice
qui n'existe pas et qui fera une moyenne
de 2 entre des très hauts revenus et des
très bas revenus et les traits part
revenu monsieur le ministre
ils sont très nombreux dans ce pays
merci monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
merci monsieur v ans a pu amortir sa
première séance au sénat
nos prochaines questions d'actualité
auront lieu le 26 février 2020 d'un
séance est suspendue elle reprendra à
16h30 pour l'examen de la proposition de
loi visant à garantir le libre choix du
consommateur dans le cyberespace
la séance est suspendue
voilà c'est la fin des questions au
gouvernement une séance marquée par un
échange très tendu entre marie pierre de
la gontrie et le premier ministre alors
la sénatrice socialiste a qualifié le
départ précipité d'agnès busan pour
remplacer benjamin griveaux dans la
course à la mairie de paris de crash
politique
pour elle cette décision relève de
l'improvisation elle a fustigé un
gouvernement qui ne cesse de surprendre
par sa légèreté son mépris selon ses
mots edouard philippe a répondu par la
tacc lui rétorquant que je cite sur ton
son ton ferme pardon indiqué peut-être
de la fébrilité alors il a poursuivi en
louant les qualités d'agnès busin comme
ministre comme il l'avait fait la veille
à l'assemblée nationale de quoi
provoquer des huées sur les bancs de
l'hémicycle
mais là encore le premier ministre a
répondu par la tacc et avec sarcasme en
se disant surpris que les sénateurs de
paris et l'air si virulent enfin il a
conclu sur la compétence d'olivier véran
ex-député lrm qui succède à agnès buzyn
à la santé et autant dire que marie
pierre de la gontrie n'a pas manqué de
lui répondre
on écoute vous vanter les qualités de
votre nouveau ministre j'indique
simplement lorsque en deux jours il a
été capable d'une part de vanter la
qualité des de la fermeture des réseaux
sociaux chinois pour éviter la
contamination du coronavirus lorsqu'il a
été capable de proposer que la
constitution supprime les termes de
sécurité sociale je crains qu'ils ne
doivent plus au fait qu'il fallait
nommer quelqu'un capable de remplacer au
pied levé en quelques heures
une ministre plutôt qu'à sa seule
compétence dont nous jugerons dans les
jours à venir
olivier vers ans dont c'était le baptême
du feu aujourd'hui au sénat et le moins
qu'on puisse dire c'est qu'ils avaient
bien préparé sa rentrée des classes
neurologue de profession il a commencé
chacun de ses échanges avec ses
confrères sénateurs par quelques
flatterie mais cela n'a pas suffi
puisque il s'est fait chahuter quelques
minutes plus tard on l'a encore entendu
à l'instant à la fin de ces questions
d'actualité sur le dossier des retraites
voilà donc pour les temps forts de ces
questions au gouvernement tout de suite
plus analysé de décryptage avec vous et
vos invités tam
merci beaucoup à l'iss pour toutes ces
explications et ce décryptage de la
séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement tout de suite on va se
rangeant rendre salle des conférences se
trouve alexandre pousse à alexandre vous
êtes avec le ministre julien de
normandie il était avec emmanuel macron
hier lors de son déplacement à mulhouse
et alors qu'il a fait un discours sur et
bien le séparatisme islamiste à un
discours et des premières mesures et
pour lutter contre le séparatisme
islamistes à la droite du sénat et même
à la gauche du sénat on dénonce des
mesures trop légères trop faible pour
lutter contre ce fléau qu'est ce que
vous leur répondez je crois que c'est
pas vrai je crois qu'hier le président
de la république a fait des annonces
très fortes pour lutter contre ce fléau
qu'est le séparatisme parce que
effectivement aujourd'hui dans notre
république on ne peut pas accepter qu'il
y ait une sorte de sécession fait sur un
certain nombre de territoires et donc le
président la république hier annoncé des
mesures très fortes en ce sens des
mesures sur le financement sur la
formation des mesures pour faire entrave
à tout ce qui peut aujourd'hui donner
cours à une forme de séparatisme et donc
je dénonce mais sûrement les propos de
d'estrade et de la droite et de la
gauche qui consisterait à dire soit que
le président la république ne parlerai
pas de ces sujets c'est faux il l'a
encore montré hier soit qu'il ne serait
pas à même de prendre des mesures fortes
c'est faux hier des mesures très fortes
ont été annoncés il ça n'est d'ailleurs
que le début puisque le président a
annoncé qu'il continuerait pendant les
prochains jours les prochaines semaines
a comme seul à égrainer les mesures de
lutte contre le séparatisme alors alors
la droite du sénat propose quand elle
est bien de réviser directement la
constitution pour clarifier et bien la
règle du refus du communautarisme dans
la république qu'est ce que vous pensez
de cette de cette proposition il y en a
qui font beaucoup de bruit qui parlent
beaucoup et puis il y en ad'autres
qu'ils agissent et qui agissent au
quotidien
hier le président de la république et
mulhouse a fait un bilan de tout ce qui
a été fait depuis maintenant deux ans et
demi dans précisément une cinquantaine
de quartier et avec beaucoup de
l'exhaustivité le président de la
république a montré que des mesures très
fortes ont permis aujourd'hui de lutter
en fermant un certain nombre d'écoles en
fermant des débits de boissons en
luttant où partout dans ces territoires
contre le séparatisme et les résultats
sont là on l'a vu hier dans un des
quartiers de mulhouse
mais c'est vrai dans beaucoup d'autres
territoires non encore une fois vous
avez une droite qui elle est dans une
posture des propos d'estrade avec un
gouvernement qui en comparaison lui est
dans l'action depuis deux ans et demi il
faut mieux agir que parler je crois que
c'est là aussi une bonne philosophie
d'action en politique
alors cette séance des questions
d'actualité elle a été marquée par la
grogne des sénateurs socialistes à
propos de la sphère griveaux puisque les
socialistes sont en colère contre le
ministre de l'intérieur christophe
castaner qui dans une joute médiatique
interposée a cité la vie privée du
premier secrétaire du ps olivier faure
est ce que c'était la bonne réaction de
christophe castaner moi je veux pas
rentrer dans le commentaire du
commentaire du commentaire je crois que
le débat ne doit pas se faire en ce sens
ce dont je suis absolument convaincu
c'est que aujourd'hui la vie privée doit
être
traiter de manière totalement préservée
et ne jamais être mélangé avec la vie
publique je crois que c'est de salubrité
pour la démocratie de manière générale
et je sais que le ministre de
l'intérieur comme tout le gouvernement y
est profondément attaché très bien merci
beaucoup je leur donne envie pour votre
réaction
merci beaucoup à alexandre pour cette
première interview donc avec le ministre
julien de normandie qui était donc hier
et aux côtés d' emmanuel macron lors de
son déplacement à mulhouse
on va bientôt avoir et bien d'autres
réactions à votre micro alexandre mais
en attendant je vous présentais bien
toutes les personnes qui sont là pour
participer aux débris de ces questions
d'actualité au gouvernement frédéric
saint clair vous êtes resté avec nous
politologue spécialiste de communication
politique notamment également sur ce
plateau sophie joissains bonjour bonjour
sénatrice union centriste des bouches du
rhône
merci d'être avec nous également sur ce
plateau daniel chassaing vous êtes de
sénateur les aidant les indépendants de
la chorale vous avez d'ailleurs tout à
leur poser une question lors de cette
séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
et sur ce plateau philippe mouiller je
vous êtes sénateur et l'air des deux
sèvres et je vais bientôt vous faire
parler mais tout de suite on va revenir
salle à des conférences car bruno
retailleau le président du groupe plr au
sénat est au micro d'alexandre poussard
pourparlers et bien justement de ce
sujet du séparatisme islamistes oui pour
parler du communautarisme bruno
retailleau qu'est ce que vous avez pensé
des annonces du président de la
république et hier pour lutter contre ce
qu'il appelle le séparatisme islamistes
deux choses la première c'est qu'il a
fallu 3 ans pratiquement email macron
pour se stabiliser sur les mots sur le
vocabulaire
or ça fait des années que le terrorisme
islamiste
avec le séparatisme islamiste est en
train de le casser la france c'est long
je trouve
et puis ensuite je pense que de par son
logiciel il n'a pas les outils vraiment
pour lutter contre ce séparatisme
islamistes parce que c'est un combat
global pour lutter contre le terrorisme
y a rien eu de concret après ce qui
s'est passé à la préfecture de police de
paris en octobre ou le coeur de
l'antiterrorisme français a été frappés
par le terrorisme
ensuite les quartiers on nous parle de
150 débits de boissons qui ont été
annulés mais de qui se moque t'on
et ensuite il ya l'autre combat qui les
concerne le combat des démos bien sûr
mais aussi un combat qui est médiatique
sur l'islamophobie sur le combat
mémorielle quand il assimile la guerre
d'algérie à la shoah il fait le jeu d'un
séparatisme que recherchent d'ailleurs
les islamistes en essayant de séparer un
certain nombre de français de la
communauté nationale
alors on a l'impression que la solution
des manuels macron pour régler ce
problème finalement c'est créer un islam
de france pour mieux organiser le culte
musulman est ce que c'est votre solution
ah non ça ne marche pas à l'islam de
france il ya eu le cfcm qui a été créée
et on a vu ce qu'était le cfcm
il a fallu quatre élections pour élire
des représentants du ciem cm qui vont se
partager pendant les six années des
présidences une fédération proche du
maroc à sur les deux premières années
une autre fédération proche de l'algérie
assure les deux autres années et ensuite
la turquie c'est l'islam finalement
consulaires et puis surtout on a vu le
secrétaire général au moment de la ferme
il a qui a condamné si j'ose dire milla
en disant que l a semé la tempête elle
doit récolter justement le ce qui peut
en découler les conséquences donc je
pense que en réalité les annonces
étaient très faibles
je me méfie avec mm macro des discours
souvent ce sont des mots des annonces
des paroles mais très peu souvent des
actes très bien merci beaucoup bruno
retailleau pour votre réaction sur le
séparatisme et hamon va maintenant
accueillir et bien olivier véran le
ministre des solidarités et de la santé
qui a fait un peu son baptême du feu ici
au sénat pour sa première séance de
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
côté sénat bonjour olivier verront
bonjour alors cette séance de questions
d'actualité a notamment été remarqué et
bien par le départ d'agnès busin qui a
été critiquée par les sénateurs est-ce
que ce départ nuisance est un choix
partisan par rapport à l'intérêt général
et notamment à la crise de l'hôpital
je note d'abord et sans être taquin que
ce n'est pas agnès buzyn qui a été
critiqué mais le fait qu'elle soit
partie signe qu'elles étaient appréciées
signe que la conduite qu'elle a la
politique elle a mené dans notre pays
depuis bientôt trois ans est une
politique qui finalement trouvé grâce
aux yeux de l'ensemble de la
représentation nationale et c'est normal
et j'ai eu au moins cinq questions
aujourd'hui donc autant d'occasions de
rappeler l'action qu'elle a pu conduire
pour la politique sanitaire
dans notre pays est ce que quand même
elle n'a pas délaissé des dossiers très
importants elle n'a pas délaissé les
dossiers très importants elle est partie
mené un combat courageux à paris un
combat que je lui souhaite vraiment de
tout coeur de gagner et vous savez je
travaille à ses côtés depuis le début du
bandage était déjà député dans le mandat
précédent en charge des politiques de
santé en charge des politiques sociales
je suis prêt j'étais préparé à 7 à cette
mission je suis déjà au travail depuis
la première heure dominée de ma
nomination j'ai déjà fait un déplacement
dans un hôpital parisien pour gérer la
crise du coronavirus réunit l'ensemble
des acteurs de ville et hospitaliers
pour parler de cette situation
épidémique
j'ai lancé une grande enquête nationale
sur la question de l'hôpital public je
siège à l'assemblée nationale sur la
réforme des retraites dont j'étais un
des rapporteurs à l'assemblée nationale
etc etc
la liste des dossiers trop loin je vous
l'avais je voudrais pas justement le
tour mais c'est aussi ce qui fait la
beauté et la richesse de ce ministre est
justement sur la réforme des retraites
aujourd'hui la cgt vient de claquer la
porte de la conférence de financement du
système des retraites
dans cette conférence le may day le
medef met également la pression pour
avoir absolument une mesure d'âge dans
cette réforme de retraites est ce que
cette conférence de financement elle est
pas vouée à l'échec
moi je crois profondément la démocratie
sociale qui chemine parallèlement à la
démocratie parlementaire qu'est ce que
ça veut dire ça veut dire qu'au moment
où les députés travaillent le texte de
la réforme des retraites les syndicats
se retrouvent et travaille en
responsabilité pour l'avenir de notre
système de protection sociale
ça a toujours fonctionné comme ça depuis
1945 et la création de la sécurité
sociale
tout a toujours reposé sur les
négociations entre les différents
partenaires sociaux un partenaire social
claque la porte et décide de partir la
porte était à peine entrouverte la porte
était déjà claqué l'ensemble de la
représentation des syndicats sont
aujourd'hui concentrés sur le travail
qui leur a été confiée qui est de
trouver le bon moyen pour pouvoir
financer un système de retraite qui
aujourd'hui est déséquilibré il faut le
rappeler
12 milliards d'euros de déficit sur une
seule année à l'horizon 2027 ce autant
de d'euros de déficit de dette qui pèse
sur les générations comme la mienne ou
les générations à venir
cette politique qui était une politique
irresponsable qui a trop longtemps duré
et qui consistait à dépenser puis on
verra comment on payera plus tard s'est
terminée aujourd'hui nous sommes
capables de voir plus loin on regarde
devant et on veut un équilibre financier
et en même temps on porte une réforme
qui est une réforme juste parce qu'on
aura un système universel qui tracent
simple et pour les gens de ma génération
qui basculeront dans ce régime universel
je peux vous
promettre que cette réforme elle porte
en elle de nombreux acquis sociaux merci
beaucoup
olivier ferrand d'avoir répondu à mes
questions pour votre première séance de
questions d'actualité du sénat au
gouvernement
merci beaucoup alexandre pour cette
interview effectivement olivier ferrand
le nouveau ministre des solidarités de
la santé qui a donc fait son baptême du
feu cet après-midi d'ailleurs qu'est ce
que vous avez pensé de sa prestation
effectivement on l'a entendu cinq fois
sophie joissains d'écouté moi j'ai
trouvé qu'il se débrouillait plutôt très
bien mais après la qualité d'un
ministère n'est pas forcément la qualité
d'un ministre voilà philippe millet oui
peut-être de feu plutôt russie en
matière de communication voilà même si
on revient commander sur le fond et
encore beaucoup de choses elle d'
évolution attendue surtout génial face à
moi je pense que il vous a bien répondu
à votre question des médicaments
absolument et donc j'étais ne tague
règlement surpris pour voir que
effectivement il ne voulait pas de plate
forme et ça c'est très bien pour les
pharmacies donc je l'en remercie j'ai
trouvé que il avait là l'envergure de
nos grands ministres les amendements
sont en préparation derrière nous at il
dit
frédéric saint clair votre regard vous
sur un amour la communication était
plutôt bien maîtrisé le la question du
sénateur avait en plus une réponse ou le
fonds abondés la question qui va se
poser c'est qu'est ce qui va se passer
quand le font sans désaccord à ce
moment-là communication sera peut-être
pas tout c'est sûr il ya la forme et il
ya le fond nous allons d'ailleurs
revenir sur cet épisode bien sûr qui a
marqué les questions d'actualité et la
vie politique cette affaire griveaux et
les répercussions sur l'exécutif mais
d'abord retour et bien sûr bien cet
autre thème qui a marqué la séance de
questions d'actualité au gouvernement je
veux parler du déplacement à hyères
d'emmanuel macron à mulhouse de son
discours philippe mouillé qu'en
avez-vous pensé
il a le mérite d'aborder le sujet à
droite beaucoup jugent que les réponses
ne sont pas à la hauteur c'est votre cas
oui c'est mon cas je crois que d'abord
connaître très bien dit bruno retailleau
ce sujet sur la table au bout de trois
ans et on est vraiment dans une mise en
scène mise en scène à la fois de plus
lieu à la fois du message une mise en
scène qui fait qu'aujourd'hui on passe
beaucoup plus de temps à parler de la
sémantique à la sémantique du terme
utilisé et pas de communautarisme que
sur le fond des propositions et on voit
bien qu'aujourd'hui à la fois on a des
attentes avec des sujets importants
d'urgence qu'est-ce qu'on fait par
rapport aux mosquées salafistes
qu'est-ce qu'on fait par rapport aux
criminels qui peut être amenée à revenir
en france on a des sujets très concrets
et en quelques quelques annonces quand
même notamment les imams sur le
financement sur mes échanges et des
masques un regard de ce que nous
proposons et on travaille celui ci au
sein depuis longtemps pour nous c'est
largement insuffisant et surtout notre
crainte c'est toujours le débat entre le
discours et la traduction et notamment a
parfois la traduction juridique
nous avons des textes dans la maison
qu'ils sont prêts pour très rapidement
accompagné des mesures fortes dans
lequel nous serions même en construction
que le gouvernement et voyez que dans
les interventions
on est toujours dans les intentions par
forcément dans la réalisation et c'est
notre altitude
au delà la légèreté des discours sophie
joissains effectivement on a senti que
le gouvernement n'était pas du tout prêt
à soutenir la proposition de loi visant
à garantir la prééminence des lois de la
république cette proposition de loi
soutenue par philippe bas et également
par hervé marseille le président du
groupe centre et que j'ai cosigné vous
les avez cosigné alors moi je pense
effectivement que les mesures viennent
un peu tardivement en même temps je suis
quand même très heureuse qu'elle arrive
notamment sur les financements étrangers
sur les imams qui viennent de l'étranger
après je pense effectivement que ce
n'est pas suffisant et que garantir la
prééminence de la règle républicaine de
la règle commune
un finalement me paraît tout de même un
garde-fou beaucoup plus général en plus
importé vous auriez jusqu'à lire du coup
que les actes sont en contradiction avec
le disco ou bien vous attendez pour voir
et au diable encore non à l'ordre il
faut un brin d'emmanuel macron qui a dit
qu'ils allaient intervenir avant les
municipales et encore après les
municipales c'est une longue séquence
oui en même temps il serait bon qu'on
puisse réunir je dirais l'ensemble des
mesures à prendre et il est vrai que ce
texte constitutionnel permet cela permet
la coordination de l'ensemble des
mesures
on attend de discours nous attend
surtout des mesures on attend des
mesures
qu'avez-vous pensé daniel chassaing de
cette séquence qu'on a entendu tout
alain julien de normandie qui a dit
il ya eu des propos des strates de
l'opposition qui a dit on ne va pas se
saisir du sujet on s'en saisit et puis
la nuit aussi il y en a qui font
beaucoup de bruit il faisait notamment
référence à la droite sénatoriale sur
ces attaques
oui alors bon si vous voulez les coûts
le communautarisme est pas récent c'est
ça fait plus de trois ans mais
effectivement sa tendance à s'aggraver
il ya une responsabilité partagée de la
gauche et de la droite certaine sur
l'aliment c'est pas quelque chose qui
est facile donc au niveau de la lah
projet de loi donc que j'ai que chez lui
un petit peu donc on met en avant la
laïcité et je pense que c'est bien parce
que effectivement la laïcité c'est très
important pour la république et je pense
qu'il faudrait à la liberté égalité
fraternité laïcité c'est à dire la
liberté de croire ou ne pas quoi la
garantie du libre exercice des cultes et
surtout une république laïque totalement
indépendante des religions et de douces
tout système qui pourrait priver des
citoyens la liberté de penser et de
vivre comme ils le souhaitent et les
religions bien sûr eh bien elles ont un
devoir celui de respecter la république
donc effectivement ce cas ce qu'a fait
le président de la république hier
eh bien il a quand même annoncé des
choses importantes peut-être un peu tard
mais il vaut mieux tard que jamais et je
pense que bien sûr là la proposition de
loi qui est proposée effectivement par
le par l air et puis des partis
centristes je pense que c'est quelque
chose qui peut être complémentaire
frédéric saint clair votre regard sur
cette séquence on a d'un côté
effectivement l'exécutif qui va sur ces
sujets régaliens qui on voit bien la
droite sénatoriale qui juge que ça ne va
pas du tout assez loin et puis qu'avait
prépare c'est un nombre de textes
notamment et là dessus il ya une
véritable fracture qui de marrons alors
sur le sur le discours du président il
ya un préambule de cinq minutes qui vous
aura pas échappé et sur lequel personne
n'est revenu
et pourtant il est problématique ce
préambule parce qu'il montre
l'incohérence dans le discours c'est à
dire
qu'on marque le décalage entre le
discours et les actes mais en réalité il
ya déjà une incohérence dans le discours
sert pourquoi parce qu'en fin de compte
dans son préambule il dit j'ai parlé dix
fois la laïcité depuis le début du
quinquennat est en réalité là c'est pas
de laïcité que je vais vous parler c'est
de civilité
le problème que nous avons avec certains
quartiers c'est un problème dont le
communautarisme de séparatisme est un
problème de civilité la civilité à la
française n'est pas respectée il ya
trois semaines vous avez un reportage
dans le jdd où un journaliste par à
roubaix et il voit un casino où les
caissières sont toutes voilées parlent
soit en arabe soit en français en
fonction des clients qui se présentent
on est clairement dans un problème de
civilité la totalité des mesures qu'on
soit pour ou qu'on soit content ou qu'on
juge qu'on ne va pas assez loin
la totalité des mesures qui ont été
présentés ne régleront pas le problème
de ce casino de robes et emmanuel macron
a ciblé dans le préambule la question de
la civilité en réalité la totalité de
ces mesures n'ont parlé que de laïcité
c'est bien je suis en faveur qu'on parle
aussi de laïcité mais il a et va il a
évoqué un problème il n'est pas sûr mais
non il n'est pas en mesure aujourd'hui
d'aborder cet islam civilisationnel et
non pas religieux ou politiques
civilisationnel qui réellement fait
question dans notre pays philippe
mouillé alors par quoi ça passe pour
vous quelles solutions pour ce problème
qui s'amplifié f1 à gauche comme à
droite on le reconnaît je crois qu'il
faut prendre le problème dans sa
globalité
alors il ya d'abord ce qu'il a d'être
évoquée à l'instant d'abord et puis
aussi l'application des textes existants
la loi de 2010 concernant le leu leu leu
voies latérales par exemple donc le fait
déjà utilisé d'appliquer les textes
agir c'est vraiment le l'exemple type de
la cohérence entre la communication
extraordinaire du pont nhât public et
les images qui ne sont pas traités fin
je crois que c'était assez choquant mais
d'abord appliquons les textes existants
streit ont vu dans sa globalité sur des
territoires
c'est un enjeu de sécurité mais c'est
aussi un enjeu d'éducation c'est l'enjeu
d'application des textes on voit bien
d'inclusion on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui
il faut traiter le sujet dans sa
globalité avec des priorités
on a repéré 150 territoire aujourd'hui
qui sont montrés du doigt comme étant
pratiquement hors de france autour de
tous
il faut commencer par ces sujets là et
aujourd'hui on n'a pas d'autre choix que
d'agir rapidement de façon conséquente
avec des moyens c'est un enjeu
fondamental pour notre nation
et puis en parallèle et bien laissons
avec le gouvernement la capacité de
travailler pour améliorer adapté de
textes qui devront forcément être je
dirais et faire du yuan une évolution
notamment à travers ce qui est évoqué
par bruno retailleau
on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui il ya
urgence et c'est acrobats collectif ils
sont en traitement dans leur globalité
on n'aura pas la capacité à le traiter
en ce sens c'est un sujet qui est
compliqué à traiter compliqué aussi
parce qu'il ya le risque de
stigmatisation de l'islam
emmanuel macron lors de son discours
hier est revenu à plusieurs reprises sur
ce sujet pour dire non je ne veux pas
stigmatiser une religion l'islam et bien
visé le séparatisme est ce que c'est la
bonne façon c'est le bon équilibre dans
le discours pour vous à sophie joissains
moi je pense qu'à un moment donné il
faut aussi définir ce que sont les
règles communes on a bien vu le problème
qui a été celui de certains maires
lorsqu'ils se sont retrouvés à interdire
le burqini dans les piscines publiques
ou lorsqu'on leur a demandé d horreur
pour les femmes et pour les hommes c'est
merlin ont été lâchés totalement donc je
crois qu'aujourd'hui il ya un besoin de
redéfinir ce qu'est l'espace public avec
la vie privée mais aussi ce que veut
être un espace ui public comme celui de
l'entreprise qui reçoit du public comme
celui effectivement des équipements
publics comme celui de l'école et je
crois qu'après il faut se tenir à ces
règles quand j'ai ferry a mis en place
l'école laïque et obligatoire pour tout
ça n'a pas été facile mais y est parvenu
et après l'égalité des chances et est
arrivée dans le pays afin de dire il ya
eu de véritables avancées
donc aujourd'hui il faut y croire mais
ne surtout pas lâcher là dessus et pas
de l'acheter
daniel chassait les élus aussi ont été
un petit peu laissés seuls face à
l'afflux le maine le feu tout à l'heure
gilbert roger sénateur socialiste de 7,5
me disais moi je réclame aussi un retour
de l'état dans ces territoires sur les
ans absolument je pense que il faut
faire appliquer les lois de la
république jeu tout à fait d'accord avec
ce que vient de dire le madame joissains
il faut définir les endroits
effectivement où ils y allaient l'espace
public et appliquer la loi
c'est très clair et il faut que les
préfets bien sûr soit aux côtés
des mères et de la force publique et
pour appliquer la loi de la république
est-ce que cela n'a pas été fait
partiellement avec par exemple les
quartiers de reconquête républicaine
cette initiative du président de la
république qu'est ce que vous en pensez
c'est ça change vraiment quelque chose
non je pense que c'est bien mais si vous
voulez mais attention on va de on va de
on revienne on vient de très loin donc
il faut travailler avec bien sûr
l'administration aux côtés des maires
parce que les maires soient un petit peu
seul si vous voulez on a parlé tout à
l'heure des piscines ou d'autres espaces
publics
il faut absolument appliquer la loi
sinclair un mot vous vous rappelez cet
été 2016 où il y avait la crise des
burkinis les maires ont voulu légiférer
ils se sont fait retoquer par le conseil
d'état parce que la seule le seul outil
qu'ils avaient de contraintes c'était
celui du trouble à l'ordre public
or on ne peut pas dire qu un burqini
troublent l'ordre public en revanche ils
troublent la civilité à la française il
trouble la pacification intérieur de
chaque français qui dit mais ça ne
correspond pas à notre façon de vivre
aucune des mesures ne peut régler cette
question là on est bien d'accord
on n'est pas sûr de la civilité il ne va
pas faire ce qu'ils pensent emmanuel
macron il va en réalité essayer de
ramener les musulmans qui sont en
sécession politique avec la il les
ramenait vers la république en réalité
rappelez vous cette étude d'hakim el
karoui d2 et de l'institut montaigne
hakim el karoui avait fait une
magnifique études ou en six catégories
il avait divisé la totalité des
musulmans en fonction de leur
attachement à l'ensemble des dvd des
signes religieux
la catégorie 1 n'avait aucun attachement
à aucun signe religieux catégorie 2
légèrement on veut porter un voile on
veut pourra manger halal dans certains
cas éventuellement prier et c'est de
plus en plus les catégories 5 et 6
étaient en rupture politique c'est assez
catégorie 5 et 6 qui emmanuel macron a
répondu pas à la 2 baala 3 pas à la 4 il
ya toute une partie de haut de fractures
culturel civilisationnel avec la
civilité à la française qui va rester
inchangé dans les quartiers et qui va
rendre caduque la totalité des mesures
qu'il est en train de mettre en place et
c'est la raison pour laquelle il me
semble que ce que nous avons fait sur le
plan constitutionnel est important parce
que là les mesures seront prenable
voilà pour ce premier sujet qui a marqué
la séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
tout de suite on va rejoindre alexandre
poussard salle des conférences parce
qu'on va aborder un deuxième thème ce
deuxième tome est bien c'est le départ
d'agnès juin de l'exécutif après et bien
toutes les péripéties de la sphère
griveaux justement vous êtes avec le
président de la commission des affaires
sociales alain milon alexandre qui
avaient beaucoup travaillé à la can yes
buzyn mais oui effectivement entame
alain milon vous avez beaucoup travaillé
avec agnès buzyn dans votre profession
médicale également sur le domaine
politique en tant que biens ministre des
solidarités et la santé ce départ
d'agnès busan de l'exécutif pour se
lancer dans la campagne municipale
parisienne
comment vous l'avez vécu écouter deux
jours avant qu'on annonce son départ
pour la mairie de paris
agnès buzyn annoncé clairement qu'elle
ne pouvait pas partir quitter ministère
parce qu'il avait dit aussi extrêmement
important parmi lesquels avaient cité le
dossier de l'hôpital qui est quand même
de très loin un dossier considérable
actuellement le dossier des retraites et
elle avait ajouté il s'est même à
ajouter à ces dossiers importants
le dossier que de la pandémie due
coronavirus donc c'est avec surprise que
j'ai vues 48 heures après que ses deux
toutous ces dossiers là était abandonnée
pour le dossier de paris et comment vous
expliquer qu'elle passe bien de cette
mission d'intérêt général à un combat
politique un combat pour le parti la
république en marche
peut-être qu'à force de touche à la
politique on devient amoureux de la
politique ça c'est pas impossible
je pense surtout qu'il ya eu des
pressions amicales un peu forte de gens
haut placés qui ont dit on a peut-être
une chance de gagner avec toi avec
personne d'autre il faut y aller alors
justement parmi ces dossiers importants
que la ministre a laissé à son
successeur olivier ferrand il ya la
réforme des retraites avec en parallèle
de la discussion parlementaire à
l'assemblée la discussion des
partenaires sociaux avec la conférence
de financement du système de retraites
la cgt a claqué la porte
le medef est inflexible sur une mesure
d'âge dans cette réforme des retraites
cette conférence elle est vouée à
l'échec
c'est probable qu'elle est qu'elles
soient vouées à l'échec pour l'instant
on peut pas dire ça puisque ya encore un
mois un mois et demi de travail possible
il faudrait pas que ça se termine de la
même façon que pour la conférence sur le
chômage ou assurance chômage
c'est évident que en tout cas c'est mal
barré
c'est mal parti la cgt a claqué la porte
le discours du medef ce matin dans le
journal les échos est assez édifiant et
je crois que au moins on peut être
d'accord sur une chose on ne peut pas
parler de réforme de retraite sans
parler d'équilibré financier
vous parlez d'un discours édifiant du
medef selon vous eh bien le syndicat du
patronat ne veut pas aboutir à un
consensus sur ce sujet je ne sais pas ce
qu'a dit le président du medef le
président du medef a dit qu'on ne
pourrait aboutir que si on obtient un
déséquilibre financier et moi
j'ajouterais qu'on ne pourra aboutir que
si l' équilibre financier est obtenue en
dehors de la prise des réserves qui sont
faites par d'autres économistes il ne
faut pas quand même faire des
concessions pour aboutir à un accord
avec la cfdt
des processions à 16 milliards c'est
plus une conception très bien merci
beaucoup alain milon d'avoir répondu à
mes questions
merci beaucoup alexandre alain milon
sans langue de bois qui dit c'est mal
barré la conférence de financement c'est
ma travailler aussi philippe mouillé oui
oui malheureusement est jugée pas
complètement étonné parce que lorsqu'on
voit la position des partenaires qui
discutent autour de la table c'était
écrit pratiquement sur la capacité à
trouver un trait d'union avec tous les
acteurs
et c'est d'autant plus inquiétant parce
que j'aimerais bien que la méthode
globale concernant cette réforme
fondamentale pour les france est
fondamental pour notre nation
et bien cette méthode est aussi vouée à
l'échec donc je suis très inquiet du
résultat et sur sept ce quelque part le
mépris qu est donnée à la fois quelque
part aux partenaires sociaux même sur
les autour de la table parce que on leur
donne pas les conditions d'un travail de
qualité mais également vis-à-vis du
parlement on va devoir traiter à texte
sans avoir l'équilibré financier ça va
de vision d'avenir
daniel chassaing la cgt qui annonce
qu'elle se retire de la conférence de
financement quelle claque la porte n'est
pas vraiment une surprise non se séparer
pas être une surprise puisque vont à eux
ils ont été depuis le début pour le
retrait du texte et puis il a la
confiance et financement vraiment à
reculons tristesse la maison aussi vous
et moi je pense que ce projet qui était
quand même porté par là par la cfdt
récemment un bon projet mais je pense
que la préparation a été assez
défectueuse puisque on arrive avec papa
de solutions au niveau financier c'est
vrai que c'est compliqué j'espère
j'espère que la conférence financeurs
pourra trouver une solution bien sûr
vous savez que la loi touraine on avait
augmenté petit à petit le nombre
d'années de cotisations la carence en
quarante ans jusqu'à 43 ans
peut-être qu'il faudra modifier un petit
peu ça il ya eu quelque chose aussi qui
était qui est important c'est que en
2017 le corps annoncé qu'ils avaient pas
de déficit et puis on se retrouve
maintenant avec ce que veut dire donc
philippe couillet c'est à dire qu'on va
avoir en 2027 12 milliards par an de
déficit voilà donc tout ça c'est c'est
quelque chose de nouveau
j'espère j'espère que le gouvernement
les partis des partenaires sociaux
trouveront une solution et que le sénat
à l'époque quand le sénat aura à
légiférer sur la loi je pense qu'on aura
peut-être j'espère les les solutions qui
seront sortis des des groupes sociaux
parce que je crois à la démocratie
sociale
l'avenir le dira sophie joissains tout
de même edouard philippe
il a averti il a dit la conférence de
financement si elle n'aboutit pas et
pour l'instant comme dirait alain milon
c'est mal barré
et bien si ça n'aboutit pas on remet à
l'intérieur l'âge pivot cette mesure qui
a tellement crispé
la cfdt est ce qu'on peut s'attendre à
ce qu'à ce scénario l'âge pivot qui
n'est jamais vraiment parti puisque
l'ajax libre on reste dans le texte
non c'est un peu c'est un peu faux je
crois oui c'est un genre de jeu en
revanche demeure de parlementaires
je n'ai jamais vu un texte aussi
capitale pour la population française
qui arrive au parlement avec 29
ordonnance de prévu et en même temps pas
de financement fasse quoi donc je sais
pas si on sera nombreux à le voter en
tout cas moi à ce jour je le ferai pas
je prenais pas cette responsabilité dans
les français un manque de respect pour
le parlement on l'a beaucoup entendu
notamment et pour les français au sénat
oui frédéric sinclair est ce que est ce
que c'est ce que vous pensez aussi à ce
qu'on aurait pu laisser plus de temps
notamment le sénat qui demandait et bien
une procédure simple plutôt qu'une
procédure accélérée pour pouvoir avoir
est bien moins une partie des
considérations financières lors de sa
lecture
bon on peut imaginer effectivement que
l'exécutif décide dans sa mansuétude de
tendre la main un peu plus haut au
législatif je pense que ça ne réglera
pas le problème on a effectivement un
problème de mépris à mon avis des
chambres en règle générale dans notre
conception actuelle de la démocratie
institutionnelle a pas revenir dessus
mais sur la question des retraites
vous avez quatre économistes pas des
moindres pisani ferry président ancien
président de fonds stratégique qui a
démissionné pour pour s'allier à macron
pendant sa campagne
ensuite à guillon mais professeur au
collège de france la campagne philippe
martin qui lui étaient présents du cae
et ensuite antoine bozio qui était
l'inspirateur de réforme les quatre ont
pris leur plume dans le monde pour
dénoncer la réforme telle qu'elle était
menée philippe aghion si vous l'acceptez
sur france culture ce simplement trois
minutes trois minutes il détruit le le
texte de la réforme des retraites en
trois minutes c'était son inspirateur
ensuite vous avez le conseil d'état qui
retoque vous avez les sénateurs de tous
bords qui tire la sonnette d'alarmé et
vous avez un projet de réforme des
retraites qui n'était en réalité qu'une
question financière
ce n'est que ça la retraite c'est
combien d'argent je vais donner aux gens
à partir du moment où ils ne pourront
plus en gagner parce qu'ils sont plus en
âge de travailler ce n'est qu'une
question financière est la question du
financement n'est pas réglée mais quand
c'est possible
terrible au niveau de la population
parce qu'on voit bien 7 et 10
aujourd'hui toute la population toutes
les strates de la population sont
inquiètes de venait de la rue retraite
alors il ya ceux qui manifestent très
fortement et les syndicats qui sont à la
rue mais d'une façon générale les
professions libérales
les petits trotta director tout le monde
aujourd'hui est inquiet de l'évolution
et ça crée un climat terrible au delà
même du débat ceux des retraites sur
l'ensemble des décisions du gouvernement
ça n'impacte des leçons d'économie tu
reviens aujourd'hui que c'est un impact
fondamental donc on est vraiment sur un
vrai problème de méthode est encore un
vrai débat de communication ce
essentiellement du coup est ce qu'il
faudrait que le gouvernement retire son
texte pour vous d'aller à la chasse à
canton doit et bien je pense pas qu'il
faut retirer le texte mais il faut qu'on
apporte rapidement des précisions si
vous voulez le problème est là les gens
sont inquiets pourquoi parce que il n'ya
pas de précisions sur le financement
quand il faut et donner la neige plus
plus plus ça avance plus les gens on
d'inquiétude même si on peut penser que
ce projet bien apporte des plus on
apporte par exemple aux agriculteurs
1000 euros on apporte des choses qui
sont importantes
on en est en r oui enfin si on n'est pas
sûr on apporte la sécurité du poids mais
à ce moment là on croit plus que
personne dit donc on apporte le point
qui est garanti on apporte la pénibilité
je pense que c'est des choses qui vont
dans le bon sens mais il faut absolument
que le gouvernement apporte des choses
précises au niveau des finances y ont
très brièvement mais rapidement on est
quand même sur un sujet où il est
nécessaire de former des retraites je
crois que c'est juste le mot latin et
d'éclairs donc on est tous aujourd'hui
volontaires mobilisés partenaires
sociaux des lésés but tout le monde est
mobilisé sur une véritable réforme c'est
vraiment un problème de méthode et de
mépris et puis quelque part
faisons en sorte que ça soit une
décision partagée et non pas une vision
qui va uniquement du pouvoir central et
les un peu ce sentiment de poker pas
pardon allez on est un peu un sentiment
de poker menteur c'est à dire d'un côté
on nous dit c'est pour le bien de tous
effectivement et quelque chose
d'universel
les agriculteurs les femmes seules etc
et puis à côté de ça on dit il faut
faire des économies et on se rend compte
que c'est il n'y a que la classe moyenne
qui met la main à la poche
c'est très compliqué avec ce sentiment
d'appauvrissement généralisée au cinéma
on sait pas où est la faille
y en a beaucoup il faut quand même dire
je m'excuse je oui il faut quand même
dire que on a prévu de 14% du pub qu'ils
soient conservés ça veut dire que quand
même globalement les retraites devrait
être confirmée quand on voit
effectivement qu'un fonctionnaire
territorial qui va de toucher
normalement 1450 euros de retraite l'a
finalement touché mais il peut se poser
des questions on doit se poser bien
c'est effectivement sur cette réforme et
puis il ya une donnée qui va peut-être
pas aider un dans tout cela c'est que et
bien cette réforme d'abord elle était
portée par jean paul delevoye qui a
démissionné dans les conditions qu'on
connaît après ça elle était portée par
agnès buzyn agnès buzyn qui elle aussi a
dû partir pour la campagne à paris il a
été question d'agnès busin d'ailleurs
dans l'hémicycle vous propose d'écouter
ce qu'on a dit edouard philippe le
premier ministre tout à l'heure
agnès buzyn était une remarquable
ministre de la santé remarquable par sa
connaissance des dossiers
remarquable par sa technicité
remarquable par son humanité
oui madame la sénatrice remarquable par
son humanité
remarquable par la façon et vous le
savez parfaitement dont elle a évalué
des dossiers redoutablement complexe
dossier dossier madame la sénatrice dont
vous m'accorderez qu'ils ne sont pas nés
avec sa désignation
mais qu'il venait souvent de loin les
difficultés du système médical les
difficultés du monde hospitalier ne sont
pas nés il ya deux ans il faut y
répondre
chacun essaie de faire de son mieux et
je veux dire combien madame la ministre
agnès buzyn a été en la matière engagé
compétente est remarquable frédéric sa
claque est ce que vous avez pensé de cet
hommage en deux a à lies besoin d'eau et
de toutes les qualités maintenant
qu'elle a quitté l'exécutif
et oui et c'était attendu j'allais dire
un tel hommage sauf que il ya quand même
un point essentiel quand vous cherchez à
circonscrire un feu c'est de ne pas
créer d'appel d'air y avait un feu au
niveau de la mairie de paris maintenant
il a pris au gouvernement parce qu'on a
ouvert une porte
et donc on pouvait remplacer mais
remplacée par un gouvernement ça veut
dire que maintenant ça brûle des deux
côtés c'est beaucoup plus dur à éteindre
il faisait quand même le job
l'introduction est pas mal simplement
mois d'une façon générale quand je vois
tout ça ce spectacle je suis plutôt
triste pôle image qu'ils ont renvoyée au
près depuis on publics d'agir l'image
des politiques on est capable 48 heures
changer d'avis quotidien que l'intérêt
général passe après les intérêts
particuliers la pluie comme arches pour
cette élection je trouve c'est un triste
spectacle qui est donné à l'ensemble de
la truffe par la classe politique et aux
français et donc je suis plutôt moins
pénalisés par cette attitude des
organisations alors après oui en excuse
a effectivement était une belle image du
gouvernement
certains suis ministre compétent avec
des dossiers importants et fondamentaux
actuellement ses décisions c'était
effectivement quelqu'un d'emblématique
et là on n'a pas eu le sentiment du tout
qu'elle avait très envie de partir à la
mairie de paris on a eu le sentiment de
la verse et qu'on la précipitation là
c'est alors la face à sion pour ta
sonntag révèle daniel chez moi j'ai
toujours vu des ministres qui sont
partis se présenter aux élections
peut-être si la liste est longue
alors bon c'est quelqu'un qui était
compétent il est certain que l'ondam
c'est à dire le budget de la sécurité
sociale a augmenté de 2% depuis 2012
donc c'est on le financement des
hôpitaux consomme 4 % donc ça veut dire
que on est on a limité les
investissements et on arrive à des
grandes difficultés
bon là le l'ondam un petit peu plus
augmenté mais encore pas suffisamment
madame busin à préparer l'avenir au
niveau de la médecine dans les zones
difficiles en supprimant le numerus
clausus mais vous savez que pour former
un médecin il faut dix ans il ya
certaines pollutions chose qu'elle a mis
en place qui vont marcher
progressivement je l'espère mais pour
l'instant on a vu le résultat
sur le plan en tout cas des zones
difficiles et au niveau des au niveau
des hôpitaux on a aussi beaucoup de
postes qui ne sont pas pour eu à la fois
au niveau des infirmières et des
médecins a claqué oui mais je crois que
la question c'est pas la qualité de sa
capacité à apporter des réformes au sein
du gouvernement
c'est la méthode qui est employée
aujourd'hui portait pas le premier ni ce
qui fait qu abandonner les gens sur des
plombs et que regarde un enjeu qui est
un enjeu électoral et une situation de
crise et bien on prend un scénario moi
c'est surtout ça la vraie difficulté
c'est le manque de respect généralisé
quoi pour conclure un mot alors on est
loin des grands enjeux de l'hôpital et
on en revient plutôt début de notre
discussion sur le fait que ce n'est pas
très glorieux mais le ministre de
l'intérieur christophe castaner a
déclaré ce matin à la radio qui
s'étonnait des leçons de morale
d'olivier fort car il l'avait lui-même
accompagné dans cette ville
et dans ces séparations j'en parle parce
qu'il a était question de cette séquence
forte des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement que penser de ce type de
prise de parole sophie joissains moi je
pense que si on peut éviter de parler de
la vie privée des uns et des autres
c'est tout de même mieux ça ça parait
sommes même prêts pour que le goût que
le gouvernement qui a eu ce problème là
avec benjamin griveaux reviennent sur ce
terrain là pour répondre avec cette
parole de christophe castaner c'est non
je crois que là il ya eu un dérapage un
dérapage il est condamné à droite comme
à gauche un ajustement que pas de
nouveaux mauvaise image que l'on donne
de la classe politique
voilà temps je crois que moi je suis
plutôt de nouveau peiné par ce type
d'attitude quoi autant ce qui s'est
passé avec benjamin griveaux assez
complètement lamentable et ça peut
remettre démocratie en jeu un bon mais
après je pense que ce qu'a dit le
ministre
c'est pas non plus très glorieux c'est
pas trés ce n'est pas très glorieux il
aurait mieux fait de tourner sa langue
sept fois dans sa bouche c'est aussi ce
que vous pensez frédéric faire si j'ai
ma théorie de l'appel d'air juste avant
il ya encore un appel d'air on repart
d'une problématique locale et aurait
impliqué un membre du gouvernement qui
en plus de ça et décrié qui est contesté
dans l'opinion qui est contesté dans la
classe politique qui traîne un certain
nombre de deux casseroles en matière de
communication pendant la crise de gilet
jaune y en ait eu un certain nombre donc
aujourd'hui pour christophe castaner si
j'étais à la place de son conseiller en
communication je lui dis je lui dirais
de se faire un petit peu vraiment sur le
terrain enfin moi j'étais ce week-end
sur le terrain quand j'ai tout ça mais
la séquence griveaux busin castetner la
peau c'est que lorsque vous êtes auprès
des habitants sera lorsqu'elle s'est
étonné marché cédées une image de la
politique et notamment de ce
gouvernement a cédé tester quoique les
couacs ont commencé en janvier sur
différents terrains déplacement des
manuels maquereau en israël retour sur
la guerre d'algérie ça a été soulignée
par bruno retailleau soleure sûr sûr sûr
et là on est sûr de quoi vraiment de
communication et bars
la vie privée après vous avez la
question busin qui est finalement une
question très politique aussi parce que
emmanuel macron manque de monde c'est
pas pour rien que si bête ndiaye ses
conseillers sont aujourd'hui au
gouvernement c'est parce qu'il manque de
personnel politique donc buzeins est
débarqué probablement pour une raison de
personnel politique compétent donc on
sent bien que ils sont ils sont sûrs
régime dans le dans l'âme acronis ça
pose un sérieux problème parce que c'est
quand même l'image de la france à
l'international et auprès des français
face à ces demandes sur le banc des
remplaçants à la macro ni bon on verra
en tout cas on fait bon courage à
olivier verront à sa tâche actuellement
merci à tous les cadres d'avoir
participé à ces débrief des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
merci à vous d'avoir suivi cette
émission très bonne soirée sur cuir file
merci
[Musique]